foreign
yes
thank you
good morning sir good morning how are
you doing very well thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
thank you
[Music]
just made breakfast for all of them this
morning
good morning
how are you good morning
good morning sir good morning
foreign
foreign
Circuit Court of Fairfax county is now a
session Seattle may ask erotic reside
good morning Judy all right thank you
apologize we had a delayed juror but now
we have all the jury so we're good to go
all right do we have preliminary matters
all right sure
are you ready for the jury then
okay
um
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen all right your next witness
we'd like to call Bruce Witkin and it's
by deposition designation all right and
who's first
um I think we are
I think we asked questions first all
right thank you thank you
will Council please stipulate that lieu
of formally swearing in the witness the
reporter will instead ask witness to
acknowledge that their testimony will be
true under the penalties of perjury the
council will not object to the
admissibility of the transcript based on
perceiving this way and that the
witnesses verified that he is in fact
Bruce Witkin
yes I am
Mr Q uh I so agree and could you please
state your name
's address for the record please
Bruce Wicken
to California
91607
and how did you meet
um he joined a band that I was in in
Florida
ended
did Def ever become family
to me
yeah who's the first person that deaf
married
my sister-in-law Gloria and Allison yes
okay and was that around the time
it's right when we moved out here in
1984.
so how long have you
been gotta be over 40 maybe from 82 to
now and would you consider yourself
friends with Mr Depp
um we were until about four years ago
yeah
um and before four years ago were you
close friends
yeah I would consider them my best
friend yeah
was he like a brother to you before four
years ago I mean yeah we were brothers
you would call me a brother I'd call him
about it yeah
we had a lot in common
yeah I mean he was he was friends with
my mom my mom loved him I mean yeah we
had a
we're as close as you can get
and you agreed to tell the truth today
regardless of your your close past
friendship with Mr Depp tell the truth
either way yes
from about 2
000 until 2016 how often do you think
that you would
how often do you estimate that you would
have communicated with Mr death
a lot we were working a lot of music
together
um
we did a film
together well he did this I might just
helped record some stuff
um a lot a lot of time between that
power but him and I spent a lot of time
from around 2001
until 2015. you know
based on your personal observations from
2011 to 2
the
reviews
yeah I mean
I mean I think the abuse is the wrong
word but you know I think that yeah it
was
yeah we've gone on you know it wasn't
like
crazy Rock and Roll House no it was just
yeah
but I wouldn't bother
abuse what word would you use instead of
abuse
getting high
what oh getting high
okay getting high on on
cocaine you know once in a while if I
saw it you know I mean I've a handful of
times I saw it
I don't think he
'd like to do it in front of me
did you ever Reserve uh forget
after you've been drinking or using
soaps and stoves forgetfulness no I
think that he's got a pretty good memory
but
you know my personal experience with him
though
did Mr Duff's drugs or alcohol ever
impact the band when you were band mates
or it's music performances we were all
young no it was we were kids we all did
bad stuff in
are you aware of Mr Duff achieving any
period of sobriety during the years that
you've known him yeah
and when was that
it's hard for me to I mean it was right
around we'd have to look it up when he
did Lone Ranger he seemed really kind of
focused and
wasn't drinking
I went to visit him
I believe it was New Mexico Amber was
there everything was like different you
know it was
he was proud of it he wasn't drinking
and I think he was smoking a little weed
but that was it
and do you remember about what year that
was
feeling it's 2013 but I'd have to look
to see when
Lone Ranger was is there a time that you
believed that Mr debt needed help with
substance abuse
as a friend yeah
in relation to Mr death
um
I don't have a strong opinion Dr Kipper
but I'll be honest as I can
he was a doctor brought on
I believe to
help him get sober he was a sober doctor
and
I believe he had a nurse
with Johnny and a nurse with Amber
at the time
um
I thought it was a scam I thought it was
a complete rip-off
but
that's just me please bring up exhibit
three
okay does this look like a through an
accurate copy of of this exchange yeah
and regarding the lines I'm real worried
about him and this Dr Kipper
um what did you what did you mean by
that
like I said I didn't trust this guy and
were you ever worried about Mr Depp's
health
um
yeah I mean I would be you know
I love the guy
I didn't know what he was taking but
they just both seemed like zombies
and why were you concerned
just because I saw how he looked and
know what he's going through and
so yeah I was concerned but
there's no couldn't get back in there to
try and help were you nervous for him in
relation to to drugs and alcohol yes
so you did have some health concerns or
not
well I
yeah I mean like I said we're not as
young as we used to be and
you know there was a part during that
time that he was hitting there pretty
hard you could tell
and
I just didn't want anything to happen to
those concerns related to Mr Debb's
health
stroke and alcohol use yes
back to Kipper for a moment
um do you know if when Dr Kipper
prescribed drugs
would Mr Depp also
take anything else besides that for
example would Mr Depp drink alcohol or
use other drugs in addition to
prescription drugs 2011 to 2016. the
answer would be yes it just seemed odd
to me that there was weed and
um wine and a soberness
didn't make sense to me
uh and has Amber been nice to you since
you've met her Amber was always very
nice to me yes and we would you consider
Mr depsby a romantic person
yeah I think so
and why do you say that
just by the way I've seen him act you
know and have you noticed a certain
intensity of Mr death's relationships
yes and have you ever observed Mr Depp
exhibit any jealousy when he's been in a
relationship yes
and can you remember when
you go all the way back to my
sister-in-law I mean you can definitely
have a jealous streak in him
can you remember any specific examples
um
you know when he was younger he was
jealous in the cage or jealous of Adam
and because my sister-in-law knew them
regular times
yeah you know he brought up a few with
Vanessa which were ridiculous A lot of
it was in his head and not in reality
you know what I mean and what about with
Amber did you ever uh encounter any
talk from JD of jealousy with respect to
Amber
yeah there were a couple mentions if she
was doing a movie with some guy or
stuff like that in terms of jealousy
would anything make Mr Depp more bother
or less bothered
like I said it would if she was on a
film or
doing something that he couldn't be
around it to
see what was going on I think it would
he'd work himself up you know
[Music]
right your name is in the um
participants column and him or Mr Depp
is in the problem column right and it's
dated February 4th 2014.
um did Mr death ever tell you that he
had a big fight with with Amber at any
time
he would mention when [ __ ] was rough
yeah
you know they were having issues yeah he
would mention it do you have any
personal knowledge of
observing
um Mr Depp and Mr Manson together
yeah but you can't blame somebody's drug
abuse on somebody else but yeah him and
Manson will hit it pretty hard as well
and they would if I hit it hard they
would do they would drink and
smoke weed I don't know if I ever saw
Mansion dubo but
I would assume that he did
he's done everything else
but you would see them drink together
yeah
I worked with them both on a few things
so let's go to exhibit eight
on text exchange between you and Amber
and do you have a I have a vagrant
memory of him hanging at Madison's house
for a couple days
you know what kind of professional help
more specifically
I mean yeah to kind of clean up I mean
he tried to clean up a couple times and
he did
I think he needed that and he needed
therapy
but I recommended that to him he did it
a little bit but then he stopped
um
because
in my experience it's deep-rooted issues
that he's dealing with it has nothing to
do with him
that's my opinion
um
so you're referring to two types of
professional help there one was therapy
and one was cleaning up uh for drugs is
that fair yeah
could we please bring up exhibit nine so
this is actually a continuation of that
same date exchange from February
uh third 2014
um and I'll give you a minute to read it
their text between uh you and Amber
right
do you think that you were going over
there uh
out of concern I mean I obviously was
she was concerned so I was concerned and
um
uh you know
going to Mansions would have been
interesting because I don't know if he
would have left
but I was trying to get there I know it
looks like I was trying to get through
the mansion and find out where they were
the last exchange yeah probably what I
was doing is reaching out to the
assistants to see where the [ __ ] he was
and how he was
obviously I didn't get any real answers
um can I please bring up uh exhibit 12
April 20th of 2016. okay
how often around were you around Mr Depp
at this time in April of 2016. probably
a bit depending if we were rehearsing or
recording
and my dates are a little squirrely but
yeah probably a bit
do you have any memories of at this time
of Mr Duck getting high or drunk
um
I mean drinking while we were working
yeah smoking weed yeah so I think your
prior testimony was that you've not
observed arguments between Mr death and
Amber is that correct or or is that
wrong
um I've never seen them
physically abuse each other no
and did you say this was at three in the
morning when he called it was late I
can't exactly what it was it was later
than I imagined that I'd get a call so I
thought it was
done something bad so yeah I went down
so Stephen called at around three in the
morning
and then you went down and you're
understanding you went down after that
call yeah
and what was your understanding of the
reason you were called
yeah it was just crazy arguing and
stuff going on down there and for some
reason he thought I could help
what what was crazy about it
right I mean I think what was crazy to
me is that's the first time that ever
happened
you know the first time Stephen ever
called me
for help like that
you know usually it's just a common
record or go do this or go do that but
for some reason
he wanted me to come and when Stephen
called you did he make any references to
anything being thrown around
that I don't remember
no
it was almost like shit's going crazy
down here can you come
he went a house downtown
at three in the morning maybe 20 minutes
did you ever talk to Amber when you went
over that morning
not really it was it was just a lot of
walking around and people going in and
out of the bedroom
um
I don't remember if people were crying I
don't remember any of that stuff it was
just like a polarity
um
you know I don't remember talk if I
talked to her I'm sure I would probably
said everything's gonna be all right but
like I by the time I got there I can you
can tell there was a vibe in the house
but
there's nothing I could Witness
what was the vibe in the house yeah just
people you know a little bit of an edge
and look I got called down there at
three in the morning and there's the mom
up I mean it was obviously
to me something went down
I didn't see anything
if I could pull up exhibit 13 please and
do you recognize the person in this
picture
yep
who is it
Amber Heard this picture is
alh in case you can't see the base
number
seven 101 uh it's dated March 23 2013.
um Mr Witkin
you mentioned previously that you had
seen bruises on Amber's upper arm one
time yes one time
this look like the bruise you saw on
Amber's upper arm Mr Witkin
um what did they what did the Brews that
you saw in Amber look like
I mean it looks similar to that but it
didn't look like a it looked like a grab
not a punch but just somebody grabbed or
hot and do you remember what year or
time frame that brews
that you saw was
I'd have to go through
the dates
um we were working on a
Keith Richards documentary
and Johnny and her showed up to the
studio and I just hadn't noticed it on
their own
I don't know if it's the same date or
not
did the bruise look like this Bruce it's
in the same vicinity
that's the one can you tell me more
specifics about that bruise what did it
looked like
I said it just looked like she was
grabbed
that's what it seemed to be finger
finger marks
no and and when did you see Mr Depp with
a fat lip
um
I'm thinking it sometime
and
it's either 2015 or 16 during rehearsal
can you be more precise precisive
about a month do you think it could have
been
in the spring of 2015. yeah I don't
remember I mean we toured spring to
summer so yeah maybe it's the spring of
15 or 16. I think it was 16.
think
[Music]
um
we did do other rehearsals for others
spot gigs so I could be off by here
if we could bring up exhibit 15 please
if you look at the first text Mr Wiccan
um it's from
Mr Depp it says I'm good just got a [ __ ]
finger right and the second text
that's from dude yeah and do you do you
remember what you would have been
concerned about just the fact that some
of our finger got cut off and he's got
doctors around him that are supposed to
be making them sober and everything's
supposed to be better and it wasn't
did Mr death ever um talk to you about
about that about sobering up
a little bit he just said you know hey
wasn't his cup of tea didn't believe in
a higher power
he didn't believe sobering up was his
cup of tea well he just didn't believe
in a higher power if he was going to do
it he'd do it his own way
do you remember any specific incidents
of Amber with of anger with Amber I mean
he would talk about frustrations or
whatever and we would try and talk
through it but
there wasn't as much anger as it was
much it was like confusion and sadness
and
why is it's not working
you know
but no he would never very rarely would
it be a specific reason why
and did you notice any increase or
decrease in Mr Depp's anger when he was
he was didn't notice much of a
difference you know did you ever see Mr
Depp doing drugs with
bandmates
yes did you ever see Mr Depp doing drugs
with Joe Perry
yes and what types of drugs did you see
them do
they were doing cocaine
and
how do you know they were doing cocaine
because I was in the room
and around what time was that
it was it was pretty late
what year
it had to be 2016 because that's why
we're on the road
have you ever seen Mr death do cocaine
before 2016. yes
and when was that
probably 2014
the first time I saw him do it because I
was quite surprised because when we were
kids he hated this stuff
um
but then after that when I kind of said
while you're doing this he he kind of
hid it from me for a long time until
I believe in 2016. and do you have any
recollection of steps Mr Depp took in
December 2015 to try to assist in
decreasing spending
I don't know all the details about it
there was obviously another lawsuit of
that whole thing
um
but I do know leading up to that time he
needed to slow down on spending
I heard about that
did Mr duck tell you about that yeah
what'd he say
sorry
just something about
the business manager and
you know I've been spending too much
and I need to slow down or do more
movies or whatever have you been
involved in Mr Depp's
prior any of Mr dad's prior lawsuits
um yes I have
I was part of the first one against the
Management Group
and then I was deposed and uh
lawsuit of with his lawyer
um Jacob did you testify do you remember
testifying about drug and alcohol use
and that
yes
and
what was that about
um
if I went I was at Johnny's House things
were going good we were hanging out
talking
um
and I guess Waldman came in and Johnny
introduced me and
I just remember Walton and saying hey
nice to meet you and
Johnny had told Waldman that I was part
of Unison music which was named in the
lawsuit and if uh
and if if they needed any paperwork from
me that I had all my paperwork and tax
returns
and Waldman turned right me looked me in
the eye and just said you got any [ __ ]
on the mandels and I said no
let's see that's the last time I saw him
and you also testified in the boom case
is that is that right
yeah did you testify to Mr def's drug
and alcohol use in that
testimony
um I believe I did how did Mr duck
respond to your testimony
all right happy not happy and what's
your relationship with Mr death now what
happened in the last four years
honestly I don't know somehow
I started to feel a distance end of
2017.
we had a gig
um
and
I saw him but he was really kind of
distant and kind of [ __ ] up and
um
it's like he wrote me this weird text
saying I stabbed him in the back and
bad mouth him and I'm like what are you
talking about and he wouldn't explain it
and
pretty much I haven't seen him since
2018.
didn't even get to have the whole Pro
argument just cut off
can't get through it and no return tax
no no
email my daughter even got married
so
I think there's some people behind the
scenes
talking [ __ ] about me because everybody
always tried to position themselves oh
who's the best friend and who's this
that when I was just there to be his
friend
and I think there were some lies and
um
what she had said about me that he
actually believed which is surprising
and I've yet to have the conversation
with him you know what are you talking
about
I know that he wasn't happy about my
testimony but
I wasn't gonna lie
and um
did you ever try and help Mr Depp
oh yeah I tried
do you ever try and help him with
substance abuse
I mean I got him with a therapist
um but never tried an intervention or
nothing like that
we would just talk about it oh yeah I'll
be all right I'll be all right so well
you're not all right
and [ __ ] would just move on to the next
conversation
um
I mean I know Christie's sister
um was always concerned with his
well-being whether it was substance
abuse or not
um
and everybody
I think deep down inside was but
like I said the people on payroll won't
really say much they'll try but
what you know they don't want to lose
their job
and I'm not saying they all fall into
that category you know but
it's a strange thing around people like
him everybody wants something and I
think today you've testified to see
that you have no knowledge one way or
another
of violence
not personal knowledge no you mentioned
before that
um has
do away
in the last four years is that right yes
um has Jay has Mr Depp ever admitted
being violent to you
no with anyone
no
all right yes ma'am your next Witness
I'm sorry just one more time yeah you're
honor we'd like to call Tracy Jacobs uh
she's also by deposition designation and
it begins with me all right questions
all right thank you
foreign
Tracy Renee Jacobs Los Angeles
California and what is your current
occupation
uh talent agent
and how long have you been telling using
34 years
Miss Jacobs when did you first begin
representing Mr death
uh when I was at another agency at ICM I
think it
uh I I represented him 30 years so now
since he's been gone almost five years
you can subtract
35 years and then when I came to UTA I
believe it was 1998 he came with me
and I've been at UTA for well now it's
been 20. two years
minus the last four
he was with me from the beginning during
the time that you represented Mr Depp as
his talent agent please describe the
types of jobs and responsibilities you
performed for them
um I was his agent so my job
as all agents are was to find procure
and negotiate
jobs for him acting jobs for him
initially well I'm assuming if you were
his talent agent that you would know
what his how his career was tracking
over that 30 years you were written and
did you not
he became the biggest star in the world
and
do you
take any credit for that yes
and why what do you what do you think
your contributions were to Mr Depp
becoming the biggest star in the world
well a that he was extraordinarily
talented
and be that my talent was compatible
with his in terms of understanding the
kinds of roles and scripts and
filmmakers that would make sense
for him to work with
and being able to master the two and put
them together
what is your understanding of the reason
why Mr Depp terminated you
I really don't know
all I know is he terminated essentially
everyone in his life so I was along for
the ride I guess line 20 said yeah I'm
directing your attention to line 20 of
Mr Depp's deposition on November 2020
and why did you leave Tracy Jacobs in
October 2016.
we're down
and Mr Debb's answer was Miss Jacobs in
the same attempt to Corral the thievery
and the Injustice that was practiced
upon me by Mr Mandel and Mr Bloom at a
certain point Tracy Jacobs began to sort
of become revealed as I won't say
co-conspirator necessarily but she was
part of that little group and it seemed
in my best interest to walk away from
that relationship because her interests
were quite different than when they
started
when we started
see I believe she even stated that the
reason she kept me for so long was the
quote was the money
she stated otherwise she said I was not
an easy client to represent her
something to that extent and so yes I
had to leave the agency
would you agree with Mr Depp's
characterization of your representation
of him
oh I understand it this is the first
time I'm hearing or seeing this in five
years
um no is the answer
and and why do you not agree with this
because it's all untrue
and then I asked him
after asking if he sued you and he said
no he did Sue Mr Mandel and Jake blooms
though I thought it was prudent to ask
uh he then I asked him did Tracy Jacobs
say why she did not consider you to be
an easy client to represent
thank you she certainly never she never
expressed any of those things to me
these are things that she was able I
guess she came to the realization that I
was not easy to represent after I fired
her but miss Jacobs there was conflicts
of interest all over the place she had
been represented by Joel Mandel she was
also to some degree represented by Jake
Bloom so therefore there's an obvious
great huge concept of Interest which I
lived with for a little while and
thought no no this is not it's not a
good idea
now my question to you is
do you agree
with Mr Depp's characterization that you
only expressed that he was a difficult
client to work for after he fired you
absolutely not
do you agree that you had conflicts of
interest all over the place in
representing Mr Depp
as she states here now
do you agree that you had been
represented by Joel Mandel nope never
was Mr Depp a difficult client to
represent
he wasn't initially and it became far
more complicated in the last 10 years
of my representing him
and how did it become far more
complicated in the last 10 years you
represented
um
is unprofessional behavior
anything else
I think that covers a multitude of
things and that's going to be my next
question what do you mean by Mr Depp's
unprofessional debate
in the last 10 years of your
representation going up late to set
consistently
on virtually every movie
I would get yelled at I never said to
him you're a difficult client I never
use those words but I was very honest
with him and said you've got to stop
doing this this is hurting you
and it did
and
um
yeah
did even with your speaking to Mr debb
about Kim consistently showing up late
for set did he correct that behavior
during that last 10 years
no
and what types of difficulties did that
cause for Mr Depp
while initially Cruz loved him because
he was always so great with the crew but
Crews don't love sitting around for
hours and hours and hours waiting for
the star of the movie to show up
and it also got around town I mean
people talk it's a small community
and it made people
reluctant to use him toward the end
and when you say toward the end was that
toward the end of your representation
yes
do you recall difficulties that Mr debb
had during Pirates five
yes
did you have just one conversation with
Sean Bailey or did you have more than
one conversation with Sean Bailey about
Mr death and Pirates five
more than one I'm sure I don't recall
do you have a recollection of
the production of pirates five
having to suspend for several weeks
while Mr Depp had surgery on his finger
yes
go to Australia at any point during the
filming of pirates 5. twice
yes was there something that caused you
to determine that that was the time you
should get on the plane and fly to
Australia
yes what do you recall that being
the complaints about what I just what I
stated earlier about the lateness not
showing up to talk to him about it when
you were talking earlier about there
being a change in Mr debt's Behavior
over the last 10 years of the
representation and you're becoming more
unprofessional was part of the
unprofessional behavior is increased use
of alcohol and drugs
yes
was part of the unprofessional behavior
that you witnessed increasing over the
last 10 years of war representation of
Mr Depp is increasing anger and tendency
towards violence no
do you know
who referred Mr Dr Kipper to Mr down
I did
and why did you refer Dr Kipper to Mr
death
he has had a lot of experience with high
profile people and really helping them
seriously get and stay sober
your dealings with Mr Deb as as your
representative
that he romanticized the entire drug
culture
yes
asking for your observations
based on your dealings with Mr Depp was
it your observation that Mr death had
fundamental issues with anger
yeah
in your observation of Mr debb having
fundamental issues with anger did that
worsen over the time of your
representation or was it relatively the
same
yes
it worsened over time
Did You observe Mr Depp
lacking patience when he didn't get his
needs met
yes but yes
do you recall a time while you were
representing Mr Depp that he started
having earpieces so people could feed
him his lines during filming yes
recall the vet became a regular
uh thing for Mr dapp that he knew that
you use earpieces the lines me affected
him too many things
yes
do you have a recollection of
issues associated with London Fields
yes
I'm gonna ask you to take a look
deposition exhibit number eight Ms
Jacobs I'm going to I'll take you to the
second page
Ukraine
and there's really
part there
and then here's where I'm going to
direct your attention this is from Mr
Depp to you
on Saturday August 29
2015. you see that
yes
and
and Mr Dad when Mr debb would write to
you in emails would we regularly have
parts of it all capitals and exclamation
marks
yes
Harley's he says [ __ ] hardly what is
he talking about I think he's referring
to
uh I don't know I think he might be
referring to the daughter of a director
friend of his but I'm not sure so do you
have an understanding of what he's
talking about and with the Matthew
Cullen version
Matthew Cohen was the director I don't
know about the nudity although clearly
that was the case according to his
understanding
and I guess he was trying to get me to
kill it
[Music]
and then you responded to him I'm
already on it with lawyers and Marty
Stinger I have spoken to Matthew Cohen
twice in this am he also wants some
stuff we are doing everything to shut
this down
was there another version of one oh I'm
sorry I have to correct myself he made a
typo here which is why
Harley he means Hanley they were the
producers
and as you sit here today can you recall
anyone at Disney
committing in any way that Johnny Depp
would be in Pirate six
no
you pacified at the beginning of this
deposition that while you represented Mr
death
he was
I think the biggest star in the world do
you recall that testimony yes
what would you say the reputation of
Johnny Depp is today these lawsuits
don't help
what do you mean by that
I mean it's endless but I don't know
because I'm not out there selling him
anymore have you ever seen Mr Debbie
engage in angry behavior yes now were
you aware that Mr Depp filed a lawsuit
in the United Kingdom against the Sun
newspapers and Dan Wooten the editor
because they called him a wife
yes
have you ever seen Mr Depp hit a woman
see Mr Depp throw anything at a woman no
have you ever seen
no other than
Amber Heard
do you know of any other woman who ever
accused Mr Depp of physical abuse no
have you ever seen
in person any marks on Amber Heard
no
MS
Jacobs you testified and please correct
me if I'm wrong that
um in the last 10 years of your
representation of Mr Depp there was a
more unprofessional behavior by Mr Depp
is that correct yes
during that period of time the last 10
years you represented him was he ever
fired from a movie no
have you ever seen this document before
I don't recall this exact document but I
know there were conversations going on
I said about five
this is good news
that we were able to help him out when
he was in financial desperation
when you say help him out who is him
Johnny Depp
and what particularly was good news
that we were able to secure
alone for him through Bank of America
when Ed White couldn't get him any money
and
it was very helpful to him what was the
final
deal for murder on the Orient Express
five million dollars for four
consecutive weeks plus a great back end
which she has received significant money
on subsequently what was Mr Depp's
upfront compensation for pirates VOD
yeah he got paid 25 million with the
back end would it be fair to say
that you cannot say one way or the other
whether Mr Depp has hit punched kicked
head-butted or choked Amber hurt
yes can you say one way or the other
whether Mr Depp has ever hit punched
kicked head-butted her tote anyone else
yes
one way or the other do you know
no
would it be fair to say that you were
continuing to bring in good solid work
for Mr death right up to the time Mr
Depp terminated you correct yes the
earlier you said that Mr Debb's
reputation that he became the greatest
actor in the world right
that's not what I said but I said he
became the biggest movie star in the
world movie star thank you forgive me so
of the time that you were terminated by
Mr death in
I was in 16.
did you still believe that Mr Depp was
the greatest movie star in the world
no why not
because his
Star had dimmed due to
it getting harder to get him to jobs
given the reputation that he had
acquired due to his lateness and
and other things
and what were the other things
just you know
people were talking and the question was
out there
about his behavior
and that behavior included
I think I've described it several times
would that behavior include alcohol and
drug use
yes
Mr Chu asked you about city of Lies
and you indicated that you didn't
believe it was released are you aware
that Mr Depp was accused of punching a
local manager in the face during the
filming of city election I read that I
don't know do you have any understanding
of why Mr death needed that loan
in January of 2016. yes he had said he'd
come in and met with us and he had asked
for 20 million dollars
did Mr Depp tell you when he met with
you why he needed 20 million dollars not
specifically other than he just needed
the money was there any general
discussion as to why he needed 20
million dollars in January of 2016. not
as to why he just expected us to do it
so you just
so Mr death came in and said I want you
to get 20 million dollars for me
actually it was I want you to give me 20
million dollars it was not discussed the
question was not asked as a loan
and what did you say in response I
didn't Jeremy Zimmer and Jim burkus
spoke directly to that point I was just
in the meeting
in the meeting do you recall who was
Jeremy and Jim said to Mr Depp when he
asked them for 20 million dollars yes
they said we're not in a position to
give our clients
that kind of money
we're not a thing
did Mr Depp explain why he thought that
you should just give him 20 million
condoms as opposed to loan yes
what that made a lot of money for us and
that we should just do it because of how
much money he had made over the duration
of his being at UTA
have you ever had any other
client who's ever made that kind of a
demand
no
and do you believe the Rolling Stones
the interview the article damage Mr
Depp's reputation are you aware of any
significant role that Mr debb has
starred in since you were terminated
that you did not negotiate and get it
for you
no
did Mr Dick get the Invisible Man
they didn't make it they made it much
lower budget with the woman as it turns
out
for Universal with Plum House
you were asked about whether there was
any option contract for pirate six
and I just want to make sure I
understand your answer did you were you
involved in any kind of negotiation with
Disney for any kind of option contract
for pirate six with Mr death
not that I can recall
no
all right yes ma'am your next Witness
yeah again Mr
our next witness is Joel Mandel he's
also by deposition designation
and we start the questioning all right
thank you
please state your name and business
address
it's uh Joel Mandel
um that's m-a-n-d-e-l it's 8383 Wilshire
Boulevard
now Mr Mandela you are here under
subpoena is that correct testify member
subpoena
correct okay could you please describe a
little bit about your educational
background and work experience
um
I I graduated from Brown University in
1980
um
I graduated from the University of
California uh Berkeley School of Law in
1983.
um I went to work for a law firm in
Century City from 83 to 87 uh Carl Wyman
boutzeroth and Chico and silver
um
I left in March of 87 uh to form this
company with my brother
could you please describe a little bit
about your experience in the field of
the business management the types of
clients represented uh the reputation in
Hollywood business field
um I'll cut to where we are today
ask me different questions I mean we're
a full what I would describe as a
full-service business management firm
um which means that we provide a wide
array of financial
uh you know administrative advisory
kinds of services if we pay bills and
and and we do tax returns and we assist
people with purchases of of of cars and
boats and art and planes and
um you know we help people with outside
professionals on estate planning matters
and we work with uh Brokers on house
purchases and with contractors on
Renovations and so it's a wide range of
financial uh
primarily financial services but
financial and personal services that we
provide to to our clients
and what type
um
our business is primarily entertainment
um so uh I don't have a a percentage by
you know my guess is probably something
like 18
um but that means people that work in
the entertainment business broadly
speaking
been a business manager in LA
uh since 1987.
when did you first meet Miss Adele
um
[Music]
1999.
so if you could take us to make this a
little move run a little more smoothly
start with what you provided in the
earlier time and if it changed over time
just kind of take me through if that's
possible
um well uh let me do my best job the the
I would describe things initially as
being the way I described our services
generally I mean the the broad range of
things that we do for all of our folks
you know we did for uh foreign
you know uh what changed was that uh
reasonably early on So within the first
few years his life and career
um exploded in such and so
um you know as I said our relationship
started in 99 I think he did
uh the first Pirates film in 2004 and
and so you know it had already his you
know uh it was on a very uh
successful trajectory the success of the
Pirates films obviously catapulted him
to an entirely different level of of
success
um and that was a career thing it was
also a financial and so there was money
made from the Pirates movies and all of
a sudden the the you know the uh
what he was going to now make moving
forward was going to be significantly
greater uh his life changed and so what
did that translate it that translated
into a variety of things and and I don't
want to mix dates at the long stretch of
time but that meant
a bigger life it meant more employees it
meant buying additional real property it
meant buying additional personal
property
um
it meant a bigger life a more expensive
point
um can you please describe for me the
day-to-day Logistics of communicating
with Mr Depp relating to your services
um sure uh
so I'll I'll I'll explain this but early
on
um
Mr Depp had made it clear that just as
my initial introduction to him had been
through his sister that his sister was
acting in a what I would call a
gatekeeper like role
um and that she was going to play an
instrumental part of his life in
interfacing with people like me
um like his agents like his lawyers
um and so
there was interface on a on a constant
basis
um
with Christy in the role that he sort of
placed her in the conversations and
Communications were constant daily
with Mr death they were they needed to
be and so
um we talked often we met often but um
not with the same kinds of frequency you
know the daily kinds of frequency that I
communicated with Crystal
please describe the challenges presented
in serving as the business manager for
Mr Depp
they've changed over a Time
and so
um
[Music]
the challenge just early on were the
exciting challenges of somebody whose
life and career were getting you know
very big very quickly and and that's a
professional challenge but it's a lovely
wonderful professional challenge
um
um you know that means someone's
traveling a lot they're again the you
know income inexpensive at you know
thrown dramatically or uh there's more
staff there are more real properties
there's more I mean it just it it it
exponentially grows the size of the of
the job
um but that's what I you know that's
what I just kind of what I do for a
living so that's
um you know uh all all changes and
challenges but but you know good changes
and good challenges
um
um
my
sense of the challenge of this
representation and my description of the
challenge would change probably sometime
around 2010
um and
um I say that because it was the time
after
he had shot the film run Diaries
and
um uh he had come back from that picture
and
um
what had always been slightly difficulty
in arranging meetings became more
difficulty and what
um I had always experienced as
um someone who liked to enjoy his Divine
at the end of the day became consumption
that seemed excessive
um and the ability to coordinate and
find times when he would meet became
more difficult
um and it became clear over time that
there were issues with alcohol and drugs
um and that translated into
more uh
erratic Behavior more stressful Behavior
more times when it was difficult to
engage in the kinds of conversations I
needed to do my job and so it became it
became more of a challenge for a variety
of those reasons after 2010 and quite
frankly the other thing that happened in
this is in
1314
um you know his meteor sort of career
rise that started to
um uh you know even there were some
pictures that were not welcome
um and and for anybody in the business
whether you're an actor you know
director I mean uh
frequently a judge by your last picture
and there were a number of pictures in a
row that were not successful and so
there was a combination of events
um what felt like professional pressures
but felt like some professional
dissatisfactions
um what I said was likely strange in his
relationship with Amber the youth is
about the whole drugs
um made my job more challenging
you indicated that you were having more
difficulty arranging mediums what if any
role did increased use of alcohol or
drugs have on your ability to be able to
arrange and engage in meetings with Mr
Beck
there were stretches of time when it it
appeared clear to me that the use of
alcohol and drugs was a daily uh event
and
and so there were obviously various
times when I needed to communicate
directly with Mr Bat
um and so some of my conversations with
the people I've described involved
finding good days and good parts of days
when he and I could engage in
conversations that he and I needed to
engage in where I knew he would be
clear-minded and and so
all right
so on were there any periods that you
can recall between 2010 and the end of
your relationship with Mr debb that Mr
Depp had any periods of sobriety there
were certainly stretches of time when he
seemed better there were there were days
and weeks of the restructures of time
when he was better and and I couldn't
tell you dates and but there were
stretch sometimes when he was better and
and more often not
as the business manager you would have
been responsible for paying Mr Dr
Kipper's expenses is that correct
correct
can you recall approximately how much
per year Mr Depp spent on Dr Kipper and
his staff
um
I I think the fee was
uh around a hundred thousand dollars a
month describe for me what you observed
of Mr debb engaging in what you would
call erratic Behavior
what I mean uh are a variety of ways in
which responses to things seem
disproportionate to the things
um and so
you know there were times when he would
be upset about something and he would be
very very upset about us
um seemingly to me disproportionate to
that so
um
again
erratic is a is a funny word um
uh you know I felt like things were less
predictable I felt like it uh
you know
I I was I guess professionally in a
place where where I never knew day to
day what to expect
um
you said that Mr debb was sometimes
uh his responses seemed to be
disproportionate and that he would be
very very upset
what if any observations did you make
about Mr Depp expressing anger what he
was angry at someone he would let them
know
um and and
um did that was that sent in my
direction uh very rarely but but but
um at times you know it certainly on a
handful of occasions in 2015
um but if he was upset about a
contractor he would vent if he was upset
with a security person he would bet he
would
um you know uh
he seemed to become increasingly less
filtered and increasingly
uh
uh
[Music]
laughs
you know the notion of
uh I want to answer you accurately
you know
people moderate their behavior uh they
may moderate their behavior in public
because things are uh you know
inappropriate in a particular setting uh
people will may be upset with an
employee but they're constrained in how
the employees chastise
um my experience was that Mr definitely
became increased increasingly less
constrained less concerned with whether
he was going to upset someone's feelings
but before or or just increasingly
comfortable inventing and in aggressive
way when he was upset or disappointed
about something
and did that increase over time
beginning I think you said around 2010
um
it began to change it in up in in about
2010 and it increased over time and and
increased to the point where our
relationship began to be impacted in
2015 and was eventually obviously
severed in 2016.
when Mr dab would uh
Express his uh anger and upset uh
did he use profanity
sure
police in Mr Debb's expressions of anger
and upset
associated with any increase in
financial difficulties or having to
discuss financial difficulties
um
yes
um
is financial circumstances in 2015 had
reached
um
a a a a a point where I was extremely
concerned and had and was was on a very
very regular basis expressing that
concern and it seemed as
um uh I priest increased my level of of
expressing that concern there was anger
directed and uh you know in my direction
um and so my warnings in 2015 that we
were in very dire Financial
circumstances were not very favorable
so did there commentary
that you observed as Mr Depp's business
manager that his spending habits became
more increased perhaps excessive
extravagant
yes
and when when did You observe that when
did that begin
um
again
um in the time frame I've described in
like 2010 and on time frame um as I
recall income was very significant
spending was very significant
um and the again the spending levels had
grown very very very large
um and required that level of incredibly
High income to be maintained and when it
dropped off
um the disconnect became unfed
and what if anything did you say or do
to try to assist Mr Depp in curbing that
spending
um those conversations were constant
Nathan Holmes Kevin Murphy and Stephen
part of the
Thrift full-time staff
yes okay
do you know roughly how much each of
them were paid
it's been a long time if I had to guess
Kevin Murphy was probably paid about a
quarter of a million dollars a year and
Stephen and Nathan probably about 125
000 a year
do you know how much Cherry judge was
being paid by Mr demp as a security
guard uh we paid Jerry by the day I
think Jerry made something like ten
thousand dollars a day did Mr Depp spend
any money on charities
uh some not very much
and approximately how much
but no specific record
less than 50 000.
um
I don't recall
writing large charity checks uh it was
more his style to show up at an event or
uh sort of lend his name to something
rather than write checks
Mr Mandel did Mr Depp ever acknowledge
that he needed to change his spending
patterns and improve the situation
yes
at various times when we would have
these conversations
um he would acknowledge that he
understood
what was being communicated it would
make
expressions of a commitment to sort of
work with me to do what was necessary
and were there occasions that Mr Depp
would appoint
he was going to do better
that happened on occasion yes
um and what if any observations did you
make about whether
Mr Depp ultimately did improve and uh
work with you to try to get his spending
under control
that never
seem to have uh um and so uh there would
be
at times expressions of appreciation
expressions of an understanding
expressions of a willingness to do what
was necessary
um but uh there never seemed to be any
follow-through when the things would be
you know uh it teed up that had to
happen to make those uh you know words
real
um uh there was no follow-up
now let's talk about the tax returns for
a moment did you you and TMJ TMG filed
Tax Returns on Mr Depp and his company's
behalfs while you were his business
manager
yes are you aware that Mr debt testified
under oath that you did not file his tax
returns for 17 years
uh I'm aware that you're telling me uh
is it true that you did that you did not
file his tax returns or those on behalf
of this company for 17 years
no that's not true
um were there times that you were unable
to pay some or
summer all of Mr Debb's taxes on time
what is your understanding of what or
his numerous other vices meant
without the home drugs
depth spent on prescription drugs during
the time that you were as business
manager
there there were periods of time when uh
prescription spending was from just my
experience very high thousands of
dollars a month uh but I can't tell you
the time periods
do you have a recollection of whether
TM
G had to pay down and pay for property
damage at other rental properties or
hotel properties that missed
Mr deputies because of damage to the
property
um
specifics I know but did we pay damages
at various times over the years
absolutely
and do you recall that Mr Depp from time
to time did commit property damage in
the rentals that he was in or hotels
and you recall that there were times you
did have to pay for damage to Mr Depp's
rentals is that correct or hotels there
were times okay
um now you had testified a little bit
earlier about needing 25 million by the
end of the year are you aware of whether
Mr debb was able to sign on for any
movies and obtain 25 million by the end
of the year without the assistance of a
lending
entity so
the first time that Mr that you that
your business you as the business
manager work are unable to pay Mr Depp's
taxes by October 15 was October 15 2015.
is that correct
correct
and you considered that to be an
increasing increasingly difficult and
alarming situation
we're trying to resolve into late
January 2016. is that correct
that's correct
I showed you earlier exhibit number
eight which was the video clip of Mr
death slamming doors and uh
pouring wine Etc in the kitchen do you
recall that video
I recall the video yes okay
do you have a recollection of giving
morning of February 10 2016.
I don't recall a specific meeting with a
specific date
um as I've indicated there were a
variety of meetings in groups and and
conversations uh alone and and and in
groups regarding how
are you know uh how these very dire
Financial circumstances were going to be
addressed and as I've indicated the tone
of these conversations became more
intense as time went on and they these
issues were not being addressed
and is it fair to say in the first half
of February of 2016 the conversations
that you have just described were taking
place
the
um
Mr Depp and I began having conversations
that took on a more heated terms in July
of 15. would it be taken clear that he
was not willing to sell the property in
the south of France and the tone of
those conversations became more heated
and more contentious
um as time went on uh because the
circumstances were more dire
and would it be fair to say that your
your perception was that the
circumstances continue to become more
dire between July 2015 up through the
time of your termination in March 2016.
they did
how did you learn of tmd's termination
um
uh
Edward White had a colleague an employee
a CPA someone in his office uh came into
our office physically and hand delivered
a letter
what was the letter from
um I think they were hand they hand
delivered like one letter on the 15th
and one on the 16th so there was a
letter signed by Mr Depp indicating that
our services had been terminated and
then there was a letter from Edward
White's office I recall it's a thing
that they were the new people and and we
should coordinate and transition
did you have any familiarity with Edward
Wright as of the time of the termination
I had not heard of
and did Mr writing accept your officer
um
for the most part no no
approximately how much did Mr Depp earn
During the period of time you
represented him
I recall the amount being reported to be
something like 600 million dollars and
uh I believe that amount was probably
uh you know uh close fact
[Music]
650
. no did you still
no
Mr Mandel did
TMG or you take any money other than the
fees that you were entitled to from Mr
Depp
no
Mr Mandel
did will you ever found adjudicated by
any Court any kind of legal entity any
agency to have committed malpractice
malfeasance or embezzlement
no
all right we'll go ahead and take our
morning recess at this point all right
ladies and Gentlemen let's take our
morning recess do not discuss the case
and don't do any outside research okay
thank you
again court is still in session if we
can
court is still in session thank you
thank you
all right we'll go ahead and take a
recess until 11 15. it's like all right
thank you
okay okay if you want to approach
foreign
this is
okay
all right if you seated in your next
witness you're on our next Witnesses
Adam Waldman and I will start the
question and then Mr rottenborn uh split
that with me and we'll be questioning
next and then it will be Mr Debs Council
all right thank you
good morning my name is Elaine
brotherhoff and together with Ben
rottenborn we represent Amber Laura Hurd
will you please state your name and
address
sure it's Adam Robert Waldman it's
Washington D.C and what is your current
occupation
attorney I'm also involved with the skin
care company in a variety of capacities
how long have you been an attorney
uh
I think since 1995
do you currently represent John C Depp
II who I will be referring to in this
deposition is Mr Deb or debt I do
and is this representation an
attorney-client representation
it is
Does it include any other type of
representation of Mr Depp other than as
an attorney client I would instruct the
witness not to answer that question on
the grounds of attorney-client privilege
and attorney work products you can't
answer that question without disclosing
Communications between himself and his
client Mr Depp as you're aware miss
bradahof the court has ruled that Mr
Depp has not waived attorney-client
privilege and will not be waiving
attorney-client privilege
so you're aware of that
so Mr two I'm not sure that you
heard my question I was actually asking
him if he had any other type of
representation relationship with Mr Depp
other than as an attorney client
I think he can answer that yes or no but
I would I would instruct the witness on
behalf of Johnny Depp not to disclose
any Communications you've had with your
client
no
so just so we're clear since we had a
little bit of record back and forth
the only way in which you represent Mr
debb is as an attorney client
representation is that correct I'm sorry
Mr Waldman
I believe that's true okay
you are here today providing this
deposition
when did you first become Mr Depp's
counselor
I think that it was around October 2016.
and what is your role in this case as
Council for Mr debt objection and I
would instruct the witness not to answer
that question
okay I'll follow the instruction when
did you first meet Mr Depp as opposed to
first start representing
I first met him in October of 2016. I
how is it that you came to meet Mr death
The General Counsel that I referenced a
moment ago asked me to go and have a
meeting with him with Mr debb and to
talk about a financial problem that he
was having did you enter into a written
representation agreement with Mr Depp
when you began your representation
or attorney-client privilege
okay I follow the instruction
have you entered into more than one
representation agreement with Mr Depp
during the course of your representation
same instruction not to answer you can't
answer that without disclosing
attorney-client Communications
and attorney work product
Mr weldman when did you consider your
attorney-client relationship with Mr
Depp to have begun
I believe it began the night I met him
actually
sometime in October 2016. yes ma'am
has the relation has the attorney-client
relationship between you and Mr Depp
been severed at any point between
October 2016 and the present
would instruct uh the witness not to
answer that question on the grounds that
you can't answer that question without
disclosing attorney-client
Communications
Okay I accept the instruction
as Mr Depp's attorney you have probably
you have you have provided him with
advice is that fair to say
that's correct
and you have charged Mr Depp for your
invoice okay I would instruct the
witness not to answer that question
can't answer that without discussing
attorney client Communications and the
fee arrangement in any event is uh
irrelevant but I'm instructing him not
to answer on the grounds of privilege
I accept the instruction
Mr Waldman when you provide Legal
Services you turning client relationship
your understanding of that is that you
provide advice and your client in turn
compensates you in some manner would
that be fair to say yes as a general
matter that's that's how I understand an
attorney-client relationship I guess
and has Mr have paid you the advice I
would instruct I do instruct the witness
not to answer on the grounds of
attorney-client privilege you can't
answer that question without disclosing
your Communications with Mr Depp
I accept the instruction
well let's go General again
and work at it from that perspective so
in in your relationship with your
clients you provide advice and it's up
to the client to determine whether to
follow that advice would that be fair to
say
as a general matter I do agree with that
statement yes
and
and by the same time
correct you're still speaking in general
correct
in general yes okay now did you did your
relationship with Mr Depp and I'm
talking about your attorney-client
relationship deviate from those general
principles that in some way Mr Depp is
not permitted to follow or reject your
advice would instruct the witness not to
answer the question based on
attorney-client privilege
I accept the instruction
now Mr Depp has the right to terminate
your representation at any time is that
correct but yes I think it's true
I think would be free to terminate at
any time
my apologies Mr Waldman I didn't realize
you were still talking
did you finish yes I did thank you
now has Mr Depp terminated your
representation of him at any time
between October 2016 and the present
that's the same question that uh I
instructed Mr Waldman not to answer
before just stated in a slightly
different way so it instruct the witness
not to answer that question
I accept the instruction
and Mr debb as the client in your
relationship is in the position to make
the final decision
regardless of your advice would agree I
would instruct the witness not to answer
that question I don't know that he well
I know he can't answer that question
without disclosing Communications with
Mr Depp so I instruct the witness not
dance
I accept the instruction
s were advising a client in an
attorney-client relationship
and you were in settlement negotiations
would it be you or the client who has
the ultimate decision-making ability but
to speculate about the question yes
generally the client would be
responsible for deciding you know the
ultimate outcome of a settlement
now you met Mr Deb after he and Amber
Heard had split up is that correct
that's correct
and you met Mr Depp after he and Amber
Heard had reached a settlement in their
divorce is that correct
that's my understanding
so you have no personal knowledge of
anything that went on during their
marriage is that fair to say
well it depends what you mean by
personal knowledge I wasn't there that's
what you mean correct you never
witnessed any interaction between Mr
Depp and Amber Heard prior to October
2016. is that correct that's correct
and you have no personal knowledge of
any conduct by either of them against
the other
prior to October 2016. is that correct
again if you're asking me do I have any
knowledge of their conduct I think I
have knowledge of their conduct I think
maybe you're asking me did I witness
conduct
there's no knowledge which would mean
you would have had to have witnessed it
if you're asking whether I've witnessed
it the answer is no
now your initial knowledge of the
relationship between Mr Depp and Ms
heard was based on your interviews with
Mr Depp would that be fair to say I I
would instruct the witness not to answer
that question because he can't even
answer yes or no without disclosing the
substance of communications with his
client Mr Depp
I accept the instruction
once you came into Mr Depp's life and
became his counsel Mr Depp filed with
your assistance a number of lawsuits
would you agree
yes
did Mr Depp terminate Tracy Jacobs as
his agent before or after you became Mr
Depp's counselor
Mr Alban I would instruct you not to
answer that question if doing so would
require you to disclose any
Communications you had with Mr Depp
it would
how long had Tracy Jacobs been Mr Depp's
agent at the time Mr Depp terminated
Tracy Jacobs and again Adam same
instruction to the extent that uh that
answering the question requires you to
disclose Communications that you had
with Mr debb I would instruct you not to
answer the question
it would
it Mr Depp's decision to terminate Tracy
Jacobs
and I would instruct you not to answer
that question because that could only
have come from Mr
depth in the communication with you
I accept the instruction
after you
've been presenting Mr Mr Depp Mr Depp
filed a lawsuit against Joel Mandel Mr
Debb's former business manager correct
that's correct
and you represented Mr Depp in that loss
against Joe Mandel in his company
I did
but it was Mr Depp's decision on whether
to file the lawsuit against Mr Mandel
and his company would you agree I would
instruct the witness not to answer that
question because it would require uh
communication disclosure of
communications between Mr Depp and Mr
Waldman as to
who was advising who as to filing the
case against TMG and the Mandel brothers
so I would instruct you not to answer
that
I accept the instruction
did Mr Depp have the ultimate decision
making ability with respect to the
lawsuit against Mr Mandel and his
company and again I would instruct you
not to answer to the extent it requires
you to disclose attorney client
communication
it would
after you began representing Mr death Mr
debb filed a lawsuit against Jake Bloom
Mr Depp's former attorney correct
that's correct and you represented Mr
Devin that lawsuit against Jake bloom in
his Law Firm did you not
I did
but it was Mr Depp's decision on whether
to file the lawsuit against Mr Bloom in
his Law Firm is that correct again I
would instruct the witness not to answer
to the extent it requires him to
disclose attorney-client Communications
it would
and Mr Depp though was the ultimate
decision maker in connection with any
decisions made in the litigation against
Mr Bloom and his Law Firm would you
agree same instruction not to answer
it's basically the same question gussied
up a bit so same instruction not the
answer
I accept the instruction
s after you began representing Mr debt
Mr debb filed a lawsuit against the Sun
newspaper and its editor-in-chief Dan
Wooten correct
correct
for purposes of this deposition
deposition I may refer to the lawsuit
against the Sun and its editor Dan
Wooten as the UK lawsuit or the UK
litigation will you understand those
references to meanness I will
what was your role in the UK litigation
I would instruct the witness not to
answer that question because it
necessarily requires him or would
require him to disclose his
Communications with his client Johnny
Depp
it wouldn't
you represented Mr debb throughout the
UK litigation correct
again I would I would and Mr Depp
alleged in the UK litigation that the
Sun and Dan Wooten had committed libel
by accusing Mr Depp of being a quote
wife beater and a quote and committing
domestic violence against Amber holy
correct
that's true
it was Mr Depp's decision on whether to
bring the UK lawsuit against the son and
Dan Wooten correct and again I would
instruct the witness not to answer any
Community any uh
would I would instruct him not to answer
because it for force would require him
to disclose attorney-client
Communications as to the thought process
that went into filing that particular
lawsuit
I accept the instruction
s after you 've been representing this
adapt Mr filed suit against Amber Heard
his former wife correct
that's correct
and you represented Mr debb in the
lawsuit against Amber Heard from March 1
2019 up until October of 2020 is that
correct
yes
and it was Mr Depp's decision on whether
to file the lawsuit against Amber Heard
is that correct would instruct the
witness not to answer that question
based on attorney-client privilege
I accept the instruction
s the legend in this lawsuit that Amber
Heard defamed him by suggesting that he
had committed domestic abuse against her
correct
yes as part of your representation of Mr
Depp you contacted potential Witnesses
is that correct again I would that is
attorney work product and that is
protected
uh in Virginia
so I would object on that basis but you
can answer that question yes or no
yes you also spoke with the Press on Mr
Depp's behalf did you not and I would
instruct the witness not to answer to
the extent that it requires a disclosure
of any Communications between yourself
and Mr death
it would
and therefore I accept the instruction
how frequently did you communicate with
the Press on Mr Depp's behalf I would
instruct the witness not to answer that
question because
um impossible to do so without
disclosing attorney-client privilege
I accept the instruction why did you
communicate with the Press
same instruction not to answer on the
same grounds
I accept the instruction what were you
hoping to gain
same instruction not to answer the
question
I accepted
you remain Mr Depp's primary counsel for
all of his Affairs isn't that correct
I
I I'm going to instruct the witness not
to answer that because I don't think you
can answer that without disclosing your
Communications with Mr Depp and we have
to be consistent that's true and I
accept the instruction Mr weldman I'm
going to ask you to take a look at what
has been marked as exhibit number three
did there come a time in 2018 that you
contacted Rolling Stone about writing an
article about Mr death and to the extent
that you cannot answer it without
disclosing Communications with Mr Depp I
would instruct you not to answer
I think it would implicate discussions
with Mr debb so I accept your
instruction
this article which was published on June
21 2018 is Stephen Roderick were you
present when Mr Roderick interviewed Mr
Depp
you may answer that question yes or no
it's not yes or no I was there for some
of it
okay
was the Rolling Stone
interview before or after Mr Depp filed
suit against the Sun and Dan Wooten
I'm not sure
do you recall whether the publication
of this Rolling Stone article was before
or after Mr Depp filed the lawsuit
against the Sun and Dan lewton
I don't
I'm going to ask you to take a look at
page 10 and it says on page 10 it was
Adam Waldman who first contacted Rolling
Stone about writing a story about the
Injustice of being Injustice being done
to debt's reputation and bottom line
do you see that
well
before you go there Mr Wolfman I asked
you a question I just read that and said
do you see that would that can you
answer that question I I thought I
answered yes but yes ma'am okay thank
you very much and is that an accurate
statement
no
what is inaccurate about it
it says it was Adam Waldman who first
contacted Rolling Stone
that's incorrect
what is correct
what is correct is that I was not the
first to contact Rolling Stone
who first contacted Rolling Stone
Mr dab
I'm going to ask the question and
outstanding why did Mr Depp contact the
Rolling Stone I would instruct you not
to answer that question
I accept the instruction
did Mr Depp authorize you to have
communications with the Rolling Stone to
set up this interview instruct you asked
you not to answer that question on the
grounds of attorney client privilege
I accept the instruction
did you assist Mr Depp with publicity
on Mr Depp's behalf
I would instruct I would instruct you
not to answer on the grounds of
attorney-client communications
I accept the instruction
in your view does assisting Mr Depp with
publicity
constitute legal work
the witness has already testified he had
one engagement for Mr Depp and that was
a legal engagement so I'm going to
instruct him not to answer any questions
about his Communications with Mr Depp
I accept the instruction in
participating in the interview with the
Rolling Stones were you speaking on Mr
Depp's behalf and I'm going to instruct
not to answer because again I don't
think you can answer that question
without
using your Communications with Mr Depp
about
Authority so I'm expecting you not to
answer the question
it was Mr Depp's Choice whether you said
anything to the Press relating to Mr
death would you agree I instruct the
witness
you reached out to a number of other
Publications to speak on Mr Beck's
behalf do you recall
I would instruct not to answer to the
extent it requires you to disclose
Communications that you had with Mr
depth
it would and I accept the instruction
Publications did you communicate with on
behalf of Mr Depp
not to answer based on attorney-client
privilege and attorney work product
I accept the instruction
s
how many Publications did you reach out
to on Mr Depp's behalf relating to the
UK litigation same instruction not to
answer on the same grounds
I accept the instructions
how many Publications do you reach out
to on Mr def's behalf relating to this
litigation same instruction on the same
ground
I accept the instruction
how many Publications did you
digital concerning allegations that Mr
Depp had abused Amber same instructions
same grounds
I accept the instruction
Mr Waldman you had a Twitter account did
you not
I did
when did you begin that Twitter account
I'm not sure of the date
approximately when
I'm not even sure of the year
was it prior to 2005 2010
2015. do you want me to speculate
I want you to give me your best estimate
I'm really not sure of the year I I
couldn't put a specific date on it do
you recall any different ranges I could
try
do you recall how many years you had the
Twitter account
not precisely no
was it more than a year
I think so was it more than three years
I don't think so
now you had your Twitter account
suspended correct
yes that's true my Twitter account was
suspended do you recall when that was
not with specificity no
Recall why
well I wrote several letters to Twitter
to ask why I was suspended for life from
their platform and the response that I
received was
multiple violations of their policy so I
asked could they name one example of
those multiple violations and they
responded by saying now they were
appealing without
asking them to do so my suspension and
that's when they sent me another note
that I was suspended for life
so just so the record's clear so you
have been suspended for Life by Twitter
yes okay
okay do you have a Twitter account now
no
do you still communicate with the Press
relating to Mr Depp
and I would instruct the witness not to
answer the question to the extent that
it requires you to disclose
Communications between you and Johnny
it would so I accept the instruction
do you still
compressed on Mr Depp's behalf
I accept the instruction
has Mr Depp ever asked you not to speak
to the Press same instruction same
grounds that
click on its face if it would require Mr
Mr Waldman to disclose his
Communications with Mr Depp which he
will not do it would and I accept the
instruction
would you have followed Mr Depp's
direction if he had asked you not to
speak to the Press I will instruct the
witness not to answer because it's an
end around the attorney-client privilege
it's clever but I'm going to instruct
the wetness not witness not to answer
I accept the instruction
as Mr debb ever asked you not to speak
to the Press about issues involving he
and them were heard we'd instruct the
witness not to answer the question on
attorney-client privilege
I accept the instructions
would you have followed Mr Depp's
direction if he had asked you not to
speak with the Press about issues
involving he and Amber Heard oh and I
will instruct not to answer on the
grounds of attorney-client privileges
I accept the instruction
has Mr debb ever asked you to correct or
retract any statements you made to the
Press relating to Mr Depp or Mr her or
Amber Heard would instruct the witness
not to answer on the grounds of
attorney-client privilege
accept the instruction
would you have followed Mr Debb's
direction if he had asked you to correct
or retract any statements you made to
the Press relating to Mr depper Amber
Hort same instructions same grounds and
I accept
destruction
have you
ever asked
the press to correct or retract any
statements you have made to the Press
relating to Mr Depp or Amber hurt I want
to make sure I understand the
instruction are you saying you instruct
not to answer in the event it implicates
privileged conversations with Mr def
yeah I I think I'm going to instruct not
to answer okay thank you I understand I
accept the instruction Mr Waldman I'm
going to ask you to
keep it what up just
a hard to read okay
um
and it's a
it's an article from July 3 2020.
it's a mail online this is Daily Mail
online do you see that
I do
no no actually uh if I'm just going to
go to
age eight
I'm going to ask you to take a look
following and say
it's Adam Waldman Depp's lawyer said
afterwards
quote Amber Heard and her friends in the
media use fake sexual violence
allegations as both a sword and a shield
depending on their needs they have
selected some of her sexual violence
folks facts
quote facts end of quote as the sword
inflicting them on the public and Mr
death do you see that
I do
did you make that statement
I believe I did
you make that state
fun attorney-client privilege grants
I accept the instruction
why did you make the statement same
instruction same rationale you can't
answer the why question without
disclosing attorney-client privilege so
I would expect you not to answer
were you representing Mr death at the
time you made this statement and in any
event I'm going to instruct the witness
not to answer that question on
attorney-client privilege I apologize I
actually didn't hear the question I can
agree with the instruction but I
probably should get that question fair
enough Amy could you read that back
please
one moment
were you representing Mr Depp at the
time you made this statement
who would instruct the witness not to
answer on attorney-client privilege
grants
and thank you I accept the instructions
sorry for the repetition
yeah I accept the instruction
did you discuss the statement with Mr
Depp after making the statement
instructions same grounds
I accept the instruction
was Mr debt aware either before or after
that you were making this statement same
instructions same grounds
I accept the instructions
did you make this statement with Mr
Depp's authorization or agreement same
instruction same grounds
I accept the interest was Mr Depp aware
that you were speaking with the Press
same instructions same grounds
accept the instructions
did Mr Depp ever ask you to retract or
correct this statement same instruction
same grounds
I accept the instruction if Mr debb had
asked you to retract or correct the
statement would you have retracted or
corrected it same instruction same
grounds
except the instruction
if Mr Depp had told you that the
statement was not correct would you have
corrected or retracted it
instructions same grounds
I accept the instruction
did you rely upon any statements or
evidence from Mr Depp in making this
statement same instructions same grounds
yes I accept the instruction
and if you could bring up exhibit number
five Mr Waldman I'm going to be asking
you a question about a specific
statement in this one if you would like
to read the article first you were
certainly at libertine too when you
could take control now and do that thank
you I will
it says and this is I guess I didn't set
the stage here this was
the Daily Mail published on July 3rd
2020.
and I'm going to now direct your
attention to page nine def's lawyer
Adam Waldman
said the various discrepancies prove
that nothing heard and her friend said
about the events of May 21 2016 could be
considered credible do you see that to
your side
okay
then I'm going to direct your attention
Mr Walkman to the next statement
quote quite simply this was an ambush a
hoax they set Mr Depot by calling the
cops but the first attempt didn't do the
trick
the officers came to the penthouses
thoroughly searched and interviewed and
left after seeing no damage to face or
property so Amber and her friend spilled
a little wine and roughed the place up
got their story straight under the
direction of a lawyer and a publicist
and then placed a second call to 9-1-1
do you see that statement I do did you
make those statements
there are two parts to what you've shown
me the first part didn't have quotation
marks around it and and I'm not asking
about that where it said nothing could
be considered credible that's not
quoting me the part with the quote marks
I believe I said that yes so starting
from quite simply
through
9-1-1
you stated all that is that correct yes
I believe so
to uh answer on the grounds of
attorney-client privilege
I accept the instruction
s why did you make these statements same
instruction same reason
I accept the instructions
what were you trying to convey to the
press in making these statements same
instruction same reason
I accept the instruction
you discussed this statement with Mr
death before making these statements
for some same reason
I accept the instruction
did you discuss these statements with Mr
duck following making newspaper
instruction same rationale
yes I accept the instruction
was Mr Depp aware either before or after
that you were making these statements
same instructions same reason
accept the instruction
did you make these statements with Mr
Depp's optimization or agreement
was Mr Depp aware you were speaking with
the Press same instruction same basis
I accept the instruction
s did Mr Deb ever ask you to retract or
correct these statements same
instruction same basis
I accept the instruction
if Mr Depp had asked you to retract or
correct these statements would you have
retracted or corrected them same
instruction same basis
I accept the instruction
if Mr debb had told you these statements
were not correct would you have
corrected or retracted them same
instruction same basis
get the instruction
did you rely upon any statements or
evidence from Mr Depp in making these
statements same instruction same basis
accept the instruction
Mr Waldman I'm going to ask you to take
a look at exhibit number six this was
another Daily Mail online
July 3 2020.
and if you would like to go ahead and
leave the article this would be a good
time to do it
thank you Mr Waldman we were looking at
Waldman exhibit number six and it's the
daily mail from July just
lost through there but uh July 3rd 2020
and you were going to scroll through it
and I think we had some technical
difficulties so we took a break and we
had an opportunity to review it or do
you need to now uh no um straight off I
I I just okay I just saw the screen for
the first time so may I read it now
absolutely
absolutely and I'm going to direct your
attention to some specific words that
are attributed to you
see that says depths attorney Adam
Walton said thank you okay
you see depths attorney Adam Baldwin
said do you see that there Mr weldman I
do okay
okay and then I'm going to direct your
attention to specifically
the end of Ms heard's abuse folks
against Johnny Depp do you see that I do
did you speak the words quote the end of
Ms Ferd's abuse folks against Johnny
Depp
I'm I'm not sure it appears as I look at
this that there are quote marks around
the statement and that suggests that I
did I don't remember saying these
particular words but
it appears so
do you have any reason to believe that
you did not say the end of Ms herds
abuse folks against Miss Johnny Depp no
I have no reason to no reason to doubt
that
what was were you representing Mr Deb at
the time you made this statement I'm
going to refer to it as a statement I'm
taking specific words misheards abuse
hopes against Johnny Depp were you
representing Mr Depp at the time you
made the statement that included Ms
herd's abuse hoax against Johnny Depp
instruct the witness not to answer based
on attorney client
privilege
I accept the instruction
why did you make this statement same
instruction same basis
I accept the instruction
s what were you trying to convey to the
press in making this statement same
instruction same basis
I accept the instruction
you make the statement on Mr Depp's
behalf same instruction same basis
I accept the instruction
s did you discuss this statement with Mr
Depp before making this
the same basis
I accept the instruction
s did you discuss this statement with Mr
Depp following making mistakes
same basis
I accept the instruction was Mr Depp
aware either before or after that you
were making this statement same
instruction same basis
I accept the instruction did you make
this statement with Mr Depp's
authorization or agreement same
instruction same basis
I accept the instruction was Mr Depot
where you were speaking with the Press
same instruction same basis
I accept the instruction did Mr Deb ever
ask you to retract or correct this
statement same instructions and basis
I accept the instruction if Mr debb Ed
asked you to retract or correct this
statement would you have done so same
instruction same basis
I accept the instruction
Mr weldman I'm going to ask you to take
a look at what has been marked as
deposition exhibit number 11 and if you
want to take a moment I'm going to try
to make it uh Mr Wellman I'm just going
to ask you it's
it's kind of two and a half pages go
ahead and take the moment to uh review
it and then I'll ask you some questions
thank you
okay thank you I've read it okay so
directing your attention to exhibit
number 11. so because there's a number
of these so maybe we can just clear it
up right from the start so we have
conversations if you look at the top
conversation
six messages three parties over 209
minutes
and it has this first one it has a date
and a time and it has a telephone number
do you see that
I do
and then it has
some email messages or text messages it
looks like
starts with
Keith Bishop do you know who Keith
Bishop is
I do and who is he
Keith Bishop is a
[Music]
publicist
who lives in London
for what
what
oh no he's a he's a he's a he's a
publicist he's an advisor on media
or
um Mr Depp ever employed Keith Bishop
in any kind of public relations well Mr
Waltman I would instruct you not to
answer any
um I would instruct you not to answer
the question to the extent that it would
require you to disclose any
Communications you had with
with Johnny either receiving or or
giving
I would not be able to answer without
doing so so I
I
said
construction okay and then Mr Bishop
says and this is on 128 2020 Adam I can
confirm a meeting with the mail online
for Monday 17 February 10 A.M
you see that
I do so did you in fact have a meeting
with the the mail online on 17 February
I I couldn't say sitting here now
definitively that we met on Monday the
17th of February no but uh I see this
and it wouldn't surprise me if we had
and was Mr Depp with you when you had to
meet
I believe Mr debb was with me when we
had this meeting
and you were representing Mr Devon
I would instruct the witness not to
answer that question
um based on attorney-client privilege
I accept the instruction
when did you obtain the audio tape that
you're referencing in this text message
and I would instruct you not to answer
the question to the extent it would
require you to disclose any
Communications you had with Mr client
it would and so I won't be able to
answer the question
what tape did you provide to the mail
online The Daily Mail
in this are you asking forgive me in
this instance relating to this text yes
The Collection is that I gave a pair of
audio tapes actually to them
whether that occurred sequentially or at
the same time I don't remember but I
provided them two tapes
what training have you had in domestic
violence
none
foreign
have you ever represented any clients
who have either been accused of domestic
violence or
or had domestic violence
committed on them other than Mr death no
and of course you hadn't
you never saw any as you would say
element or elements of things that
misheard claimed right
I never saw any element or elements of
things should be claimed
um do you mean did I ever see evidence
with my own eyes that something she was
saying was false
yes
next in I have see
ing show her statements to be full
before we get there
as best you can recall today
who are the eyewitnesses that you
um
among the 29 or so that you referred to
in the text Christian Carino that you
believe disproved Memphis herds
abuse by Johnny Depp
okay good
um
it's also probably easier to answer
by taking a particular incident rather
than just thinking of of names of people
so
um maybe this is a good illustration
that is a helpful answer
um
on May 21st 2016 and I I always view
this as one of her Central claims it was
the one she could put on the cover of
People magazine it's the one she led
with when she went to get her temporary
training order the phone to the face
incident on May 21st 2016 that's
reclaiming that she was beaten further
beaten by some appendage of Mr Depp in
the face
inner hair was pulled and she showed up
on the 27th in court with a lot of
bruises on her face
so there are
two police officers one domestic
violence trained female police officer
who've testified over and over and over
that there was no damage to the
penthouse which misheard claimed was
destroyed that's a direct quote
destroyed
um
their uh there are that I can think of
nine other Witnesses
the majority of whom
are either neutral or actually will miss
hurt his own Witnesses
who have testified in various forms
um various times that there were no
injuries to her face whatsoever between
the 21st
and the 27th when suddenly there were
bruises
um
let's see
um
Laura divinir
[Music]
um
Melanie and glacie Amber's own uh
primary makeup artist
Laura divinir was Miss heard's assistant
and decorator and now works for Elon
Musk
um
Hilda Vargas
um Mr Depp and Miss herds at the time
housekeeper
um
Samantha McMillan who was misheard and
Mr Depp's
stylist had a good friend Miss hers
um
Isaac Baruch Miss herbs and Mr Debb's
friend close friend and uh Miss heard's
neighbor in the penthouses
okay so continuing on uh the
the witnesses
a list of some witnesses to the 21st to
her claims of of violence and damage to
the apartment
Trinity Esparza who was the head of the
concierge desk at the Eastern Columbia
building and a friend of Ms herds also
Cornelius Harrell who I think also
worked for the concierge task or in any
event work for the Eastern Columbia
building and met with Miss heard on the
22nd of May which meeting was captured
on CCTV also
Alejandro Romero who I believe is head
of security at the Eastern Columbia
building
and I think Brandon Patterson also
testified about the absence of of
bruises and I should I should even
distinguish because we're talking about
the notion of a hoax we should
distinguish these people
specifically have given testimony that
she was
heard was uninjured between the 21st of
May up into perhaps the 25th or 26th of
May and then of course she appeared
bruised again on the 27th some of them
have testified that even after the 27th
they were with her and she appeared and
that she appeared bruised but during
that period between the 21st and 27th
I'm not sure if I've listed nine plus
the two police officers
but I think that's that's an
illustration of what I was referring to
when I when I in the question you uh uh
asked me that
can you please pull up
um
the document labeled arw 660 please so
smart but you do believe that the
pictures and videos Marilyn Manson sent
you helped disprove misheard's
allegations correct
as to that as to that incident uh
Thanksgiving perhaps 2013 I think those
I think those videos
uh and photographs yes
demolish your claim Have you
communicated with other social media
users
about this case
other than
public messaging platforms
let me let me ask that differently Have
you communicated privately with
other social media users about this case
um
other social media I want to make sure
I'm precise other social media users
yes
that would that would that group would
include almost everybody on Earth
have you provided information about this
case to other social media personalities
who then post that information
um
I've provided information episodically
to
what I would what I would call internet
journalists and I'll Define that as
journalists who are not affiliated with
that you mentioned I think NBC a moment
ago or a you know a mainstream media
Outlet
Have you communicated with
um a social media user who goes by the
name that umbrella guy
um I've had several phone calls with uh
with the person who goes by the name
that umbrella guy don't actually know
his real name
Have you communicated with him other
than through phone calls
um
I don't remember doing so no
um
what are other
well let me ask you this D
Have you communicated in a similar
fashion with someone on social media who
goes by the name that Brian fella
yes
um what about someone who goes by the
name the real Laura d
yes
and Have you communicated to
those individuals listed
evidence that you believe suggests that
misheard's allegations or hoaxes
um I would say
I communicate with the internet
journalists because we put them in a
category calling them that I I've done
that
exactly the same way I would communicate
with mainstream media
um
if they have questions about evidence or
the facts uh you know I'll I'll uh I'll
inform them
and have you in when you communicate
with them do you do so you testified
some by phone correct
yes do you do so by text or messenger
platform
largely I think by phone but if I if I
communicated in writing it would be
probably by signal
can you please pull up uh the exhibits
alh
one seven zero zero one to two please
carry on a screen exhibit 24. no my
question well my first question is
um is that in that box where it says
first on the record statement
um
for me regarding the body cam to RTL
Adam Walden Johnny Depp's attorney is
that
um
is that a statement that you made to
um a German media Outlet called RTL
yes
and in that statement you say that LAPD
have now opened up a criminal
investigation into perjury of Miss heard
correct yes
did you
um
did you did you make a correction to RTL
when you learned that the LAPD wasn't in
fact investigating uh misheard for
perjury
well the way you've characterized it is
not exactly what I would agree with the
LAPD told me that they were uh
investigating the uh the perjury claim
at that time then sequentially came the
statement then came notification from
the LAPD that it was actually the LA
Sheriff's Department that was
investigating it and that was the last I
heard about it and who notified you from
the LAPD that it was allegedly the
sheriff's department who was
investigating it the same uh the same
desk officer at Foothill and when I say
he's the desk officer I don't know if
that's not necessarily the job title
how did you find his
um well do you have his contact
information
uh I don't
think I do I don't know but I don't well
I'm not sure
and I'm sorry I'm sorry if I asked you
this
um how did you come into contact with
this desk officer
I brought a binder of information
um including the
statements that had been made
and the evidence showing that those
statements were false
in your view
so you you took a
binder to the LAPD and spoke to this
desk officer correct
and was that the only time that you
spoke to this person
two times
were they both in person oh maybe it's
three it's two or three times you know
um no two times we're on the phone
was the first meeting in person when you
brought this binder no the first was on
the telephone
so the the
investigation was opened up at your
request after you brought this binder to
the desk officer is that right I didn't
ask him I didn't ask him to open an
investigation I filed a claim uh with
the LAPD
um regarding these perjurious statements
that misheard and her best friend Rocky
Pennington had made uh to a court
was that claim that you filed in writing
yes
do you know whether that claim was
produced as part of this your document
production in this case because I
certainly haven't seen it
I don't know that I ever received a copy
of it it was filed in writing with the
LAPD
um
but I don't I don't recall that I ever
received a copy of it did you draft it
no
so what was you were talking to the desk
officer and he was taking down notes and
that is that the writing you're
referring to
yes
did you ever see this alleged written
claim
yes
did you sign it
I don't recall if I did did you ever
speak to anyone other than
your client about this alleged perjury
investigation other than your client and
the desk officer
oh
well I think this
quote that you've that you've shown me
to the media
would would constitute speaking about it
did you ever hear anything more about
this perjury investigation to the extent
it existed
um from anyone any other third party who
claimed that they had spoken to anyone
in LAPD or the LA Sheriff's Office
no I don't think so
Mr Waldman do you have a professional
license
I do do you have your own Law Firm I do
what is the name of your Law Firm
Endeavor Law Firm when was Endeavor Law
Firm formed
um
I think it was in 2005.
informed uh your Law Firm
uh it was I who didn't
and who owns your Law Firm I do what is
your title at the Endeavor law firm uh
managing member I believe and it's it's
none of our business who your clients
are but does the Endeavor Law Firm have
other clients other than Mr debb yes
because Johnny Depp issue you a form W-2
I don't think so no
do you receive legal training from
Johnny Depp or any of your other clients
I suppose the practice of law in general
is legal training but if I understand
your question correctly no
Fair Point uh have you ever listed
Johnny Depp as your employer on any
filings with the IRS no
but you offer legal services to clients
correct yes all right I'll say do you
offer legal services to uh the General
Public
probably not to the general public but I
offer Legal Services I think that's your
question
yes ma'am
your honor our next one would be
detective son donaga
s-a-n-d-a-n-a-g-a it's about 20 minutes
all right let's go ahead and grab that
witness and is that and good when we
start the question all right thank you
it's your name and business address for
the record please
Marie sadanaga
m-a-r-i-e Sada Naga s-a-d-a-n-a-g-a
and my business address is 100 West 1st
Street Los Angeles California
and what is your current occupation
I am a detective with the Los Angeles
Police Department and I am the
Department's domestic violence
coordinator
what does it mean to be the domestic
violence coordinator for the Department
so I am recognized as the person most
knowledgeable in domestic violence I
oversee how our department has a whole
response to domestic violence so I don't
investigate cases right now myself I
just make sure that officers and
detectives are responding to domestic
violence how California state penal code
launches
17 years
what if any policies procedures and
Protocols are in place at the LAPD
for domestic violence cases separate
from other types so once we determine
there is domestic violence
we have to determine whether there is a
crime every time we respond to a
domestic violence call Post State law we
need to document whether it's a crime or
just an incident which would be when
there is not a crime but there's still
paperwork done so that is part of the
officer's investigation
now
I had asked a little earlier about when
the victim is reluctant to press charges
if the patrol officers saw property
damage
or marks on the face of the victim even
if the victim was not cooperating and
did not want to press charges what would
the patrol officer's obligations be back
in May 2016 on a domestic violence call
if officers determined that there was
domestic violence even if a victim is
reluctant our policy is based still make
that arrest if a suspect is there or
take a report
so
if there are when the patrol officers
arrive at the scene and this is May 2016
and there are four people
that are present at the scene
how many of those individuals are the
patrol officers obligated to interview
so I'm going to show you the incident
quality and it goes down and it has
domestic dispute
and then it says met with victim looks
like check location verified husband
left
victim advised verbal dispute and
refused to give any further information
issued business card do you see that
yes okay
in May of 2016.
was the language victim advised verbal
dispute
language that was that Patrol officers
were trained to provide when they were
not going to document anything from the
scene
it can vary but officers would commonly
use
um
the phrase verbal dispute or to document
when a report was not taken
when they ask you to take a look at what
has been marked as deposition exhibit
number eight
and stated November 24 2014.
and it's subject domestic violence
supplemental report
and it says the domestic violence
supplemental report formed
15.40.02 has been revised to provide a
more concise picture of the history and
needs of the victim for the purpose of
investigating the crime of domestic
violence you see that
yes what is your understanding of why
the the LAPD decided that they needed to
create a supplemental report form that
would give a more concise picture
picture of the history and needs of the
victim for the purpose of investigating
the crime of domestic violence
right the
supplemental includes a lot of questions
that are required by California state
law so we included that on it and
the original supplemental was actually
created a lot earlier I believe in 1999
this this revision of it added some
specific questions to help us
look at kind of to do a risk assessment
um I'm not sure if the supplemental is
attached to this form but on the
supplemental there's a section where I
believe there's like seven yes or no
questions that is what was added during
this revision
detective sadness I'm going to show you
what has been marked as deposition
exhibit number nine
and
do you recognize this supplemental
report
yes I is this the supplemental form that
was referred to in exhibit number eight
yes okay
now if we look at this and we start out
on the left hand column
has a number of different
observations to make of the victim and
it includes shaking unresponsive crying
scared angry fearful calm agitated
nervous threatening apologetic under the
influence of alcohol under the influence
of drugs or other observations and it
says document in narrative
all right are these typically
characteristic uh victims of domestic
violence
yes
I'm going to turn your direction to the
crime scene now and the same question
there's a number of different uh items
on here including location vandalize
ransacked uh and personal property
damage Furniture disarray broken
what is your understanding why these are
included on this list
my understanding is that these are
um
things that are typically at a crime
scene or can occur so things that we
want officers to look for and Mark when
they take the crime report
and as with the questions I had on the
characteristics uh that are on the list
for the victims
um are these
items that are also discussed with the
police officers in their training to
bookstore in even making the
determination whether a crime has taken
place
yes they are
is there a scenario under which
the Control Officers decide that there's
no crime
but they see property damage and injury
and take photographs
I mean it
every situation is different
um
I believe well one way if we have a
situation like that that occurred it
then there should be a domestic violence
incident report so there is
a place to document your observations
and statements from people and and to
reason to have those photographs
even if ultimately the officers
determined that it wasn't a crime
and yes that's why domestic violence
incident reports are reports where there
are no crime and that is why we have
them so we can we can document
um and have a history of calls and see
in case there is another call in the
future that there is prior history of
any type of of domestic college and if
it was not ultimately ruled the crime
with that incident report
uh include if there were interviews with
Witnesses and if there were any
photographs or notes taken
yes there is still a narrative that is
that is written where everything the
officer's investigation and observations
and any photographs are listed
was there an incident report in place in
May of 2016 for patrol officers to use
in domestic violence calls
yes
could you please describe the purpose of
an incident report as of May 2016 and
what was included typically in an
incident report
so the purpose of domestic violence
incident reports
um were to record when officers
responded to a call of domestic violence
that did not result in a crime they are
actually required by state law for us to
document every domestic violence
incident that we respond to and in that
report it's the the same
I keep calling it a face sheet that's
not the official term but the same as a
crime report that we would take it on
but you fill out the information you
just do not list a suspect because we
have no crime it's the victim who was in
fear that the other party may cause
um some type of danger to them and that
other party is then listed as a witness
and then there is a narrative that is
included that the same type of narrative
that would be in a crime report where
you would write down your source of
activity the officers would put their
source of activity and then document
their investigation
uh statements that anyone made
um any as we ask on
domestic violence calls what type of
relationship it is how long you know
they've been together any prior
incidents of domestic violence
um all that would be included in The
Narrative of an incident report
photographs
also be included in that incident report
yes they can be if there was anything
that they saw that officers believe
needed to be documented in there
and
where would an incident report that I'm
again back in May 2016
where would that be filed or stored once
the patrol officers were done with their
shift for the day
the officers would turn in their reports
including any incident reports to the
Watch Commander who would read over it
and sign it off and if it is approved it
would go to our records unit at that
division to create a
report number on it and then it does get
assigned to a detective
just so that we have it on uh file
um in in case there's any future
incidents
as do officers at some point have to
make a determination as to whether
domestic violence has occurred
yes they do
what criteria do officers use to make
that evaluation
they use the interviews with the parties
that are there
um what they observe at the scene
um
even what they observe like the demeanor
of the victims and the suspects of every
situation is different but it's uh
really like taking in the whole
the whole 360 of where you are and
what's occurred so they can get all
information to make that educated
determination of a crimeless occurred
can you just generally describe for me
the circumstances under which a domestic
incident report is used
so we take a incident report
when they're we determined there is no
crime but that one of the parties is in
fear that uh you know their life was in
danger or they could
um
be a victim of some type of serious
bodily injury so are they the third
incidence you would have or where we
don't take the incident report is where
both parties state it was an argument
there was no physical injury I wasn't
both parties say we aren't weren't
afraid that the other was going to do
any type of harm to me
okay
and so
in that case in that third case that you
just described would there be any
documentation required typically
on the that third one when we don't have
the fear so it makes it no incident
report it's only documented on that
daily field activity report
it was earlier on in the deposition the
about
victims of domestic violence being
reluctant to come forward and speak up
do you recall that
yes
is that a significant problem in dealing
with domestic violence calls
yes
is that a problem that you have
personally experienced on on your own
calls
yes
when confronted with
the person who's unwilling to make a
statement
is there much that a police officer can
really do if you have if you have
somebody who just refuses to make a
statement and refuses to indicate that
they have suffered violent abuse
it's
not too much usually
we try to we teach them to talk about
the cycle of violence and power and
control and see if we can you know start
a rapport with the victim and get them
to discuss but if they really don't want
to tell us what
happen we can't force them
uh
potential victim
has visible injuries
or that there are indications at the
scene that there has been some sort of
violent episode
does the facts that the potential victim
declines to make a statement mean that
the officers can't go forward
no not necessarily because
it would need to investigate more but
you do have the visible injury and you
know evidence of some type of struggle
so they would need to try to get that
probable cause to determine that it was
a crime that
created that intro
there were a number of questions asked
about
if a verb injury if observed property
damage back and forth and both of us
have asked you a lot of questions about
this
and so I just want to make sure that
it's very clear
if a police officer
responding to domestic violence call
sees injury
regardless of whether the victim
cooperates what is the police officer's
obligation this is as of May 2016.
to do an investigation to determine if
that injury was a result of a crime
and
that investigation would include what
it would include interviewing anyone
that is at scene
um seeing if there's any type of
physical evidence of altercation or
depending on on
the story that was given if there's
corroboration of that
seen if there's any Witnesses
kind of heads each each one's different
but just doing a thorough investigation
if one of the other Witnesses
took the officers through the entire
premises and showed broken glass spilled
wine and a number of areas of
disturbance and vandalism
what would the officer's obligations be
then
the officers would still need to
determine if there was enough
evidence there from from these witness
statements and the things that they're
seeing to determine if this entry is the
result of a crime
what discretion do the police officers
have when they see an injury on the
victim when they reported to a domestic
violence call and this is in May 2016.
the officers still need to do an
investigation if there is a visible
injury because we they have to determine
if it was a crime
so one of your roles if I understand it
is to make a determination of
of the police the LA PG as a whole
uh how you're overseeing how they
respond to domestic violence calls
correct
yes
and I let me ask you just a little bit
differently in making the determination
of whether to create an incident report
uh what if any factors can the officer
consider
uh if the victim
does not want to press charges
but the officer still believes that an
incident report is appropriate under the
circumstances
it was if a officer determines that
there was not a crime yet there was
enough
there and guess what I'm trying to say I
mean the purpose we have to think about
that we tell the officers the purpose of
domestic violence incident report is for
documentation
of incidents because we know with
domestic violence there's usually a
series of of incidents that happen and
not all of those are crimes so
for us as officers we document those so
in the future if there is a crime we can
go back and say there have been all
these other incidents so as officers we
kind of take that
uh into our analysis of the scene and if
we can't determine whether a crime has
happened we have to think about do do we
need to document this so maybe sometime
in the future
people know that this happened
all right thank you ladies and Gentlemen
let's go ahead and take our lunch break
at this time again do not do any outside
research and do not discuss the case
with anybody okay we'll see you back
foreign
is your next witness on a deposition or
it's gonna be live right so we'll take
care of the TV then all right see you 1
45.
all right are we ready for the jury
sure sure
foreign
all right so are you ready for the jury
okay
foreign
your next Witness
we call Ron Chanel
okay
s-c-h-n-e-l-l thank you sir
foreign
please introduce yourself to the jury
I'm Ron Schnell and what is your current
job title Mr snow I'm a director at
Berkeley research group
and could you briefly describe your
educational background since high school
I have a master's degree in computer
science
do you have an undergraduate degree I do
not and can you explain to the jury why
not
when I was a kid there was a lot of
publicity about me because I was a
professor at NYU when I was 14
um
NYU actually offered me to go into their
freshman class when I was 14 but I
decided that I wanted to experience the
social aspect of high school so I turned
them down but by the time I got to
college they skipped me from
undergraduate to graduate
so when did you receive your master's
degree from Syracuse University it
wasn't until 2008 actually and and why
why wasn't it until 2008
so um because of my previous background
while I was at Syracuse
um including I I did work at MIT
um in the artificial intelligence lab
for uh the two founders of artificial
intelligence Patrick Winston and um
Marvin Minsky um
I was immediately lowered to Industry
even while I was in graduate school and
eventually they offered you enough money
where you have to take them up on it
so
what
so when you were lured away from
Syracuse University uh what did you do
I worked at Bell Labs on something
called the Unix operating system
Unix is an operating system which is the
core of the computer what makes
everything work Microsoft Windows is an
operating system Mac OS is an operating
system you may have heard of Linux which
is um you know Unix was the predecessor
to Linux so I worked on the Kernel of
the Unix operating system at Bell labs
and when was that approximately what
year uh 1986.
and and how long did you work at Bell
labs
um a couple years and what did you do
after Bell Labs after that
um I was lured away to uh IBM so I
worked at IBM on their version of the
Unix operating system which was called
AIX also working on the Kernel and
managing other programmers working on
the Kernel and can you just briefly
explain what the kernel is right the
kernel is the center of the operating
system so it actually controls the piece
of software that controls the whole
computer so it gets down to the bit
level where it's uh actually really
everything that goes on the computer has
to go through the kernel
and what do you do after IBM
um after IBM I founded a startup company
what was the name of that startup
company it was called secure online
systems and what did secure online
systems do it was a company that wrote
software for mainframe computers running
the various versions of the Unix
operating system
and were there any other investors in
Secure online Systems Inc yeah
my business partner in that was
Sylvester Stallone
and what what eventually happened to
secure online systems
well it was um it was
as I said a software product that ran on
mainframe computers running Unix
um and we actually completed the product
and it ran very well but mainframes
running Unix kind of ceased to exist
back then so we had to shut it down
so what did you do after uh that the
company shut down
um then I went to work at Sun
Microsystems working on their version of
Unix which is called Solaris also
working on the Kernel
and approximately how long were you
there
at Sun approximately five years
and um did you also work for drivers
Aces Inc right coincident with that I
also uh founded another startup called
driver Aces
um and we wrote what are called device
drivers to run on the Unix operating
systems
um the device driver actually teaches
the computer how to talk to Hardware
devices so it also runs within the
kernel
have you founded any other startups
yes
and what was the other startup what was
at least one of the other startups so um
the last startup I founded uh was called
mailcall.com m-a-i-l
um and that was a startup that allowed
you to read and manage your email on
your cellular phone before there were
smartphones so a computerized voice
would read you your email and you could
speak or reply into the phone or send it
to a fax machine basically let you
manage your email on the road
and what happened to mailcall.com I sold
that to a public company in 2000.
and what did what'd you do after that
um after that I um ended up working uh
at Equifax one of the three credit
bureaus in the United States uh running
software development for their uh
internet marketing division
um
and how long how long were you in that
position
until 2005. and what happened in 2005
in 2005 I was asked to run what's called
a monitorship for the DC district court
in for two cases U.S versus Microsoft
and New York at all versus Microsoft the
two largest antitrust cases in in U.S
history so I was uh responsible for
running that organization I hired 93
people over six and a half years to to
perform that monitorship and what what
type of work were you doing in that
monitorship
um highly technical work looking at all
of Microsoft's
documents and source code and things
like that I can't talk too much about it
because of a protective order
um but I had a special Master powers in
that in that matter in those matters
and you said you you were in that
position for six and a half years
correct so that takes us to about 2013
is that right it was 11 2011 okay and um
what did you do
um
what'd you do in 2011.
um
in 2011 I didn't do much until 2013 when
I took the role as a director at
Berkeley research group and that's your
current position correct correct and
what are your responsibilities at
Berkeley research group
so I do all sorts of things I um
generally I consult I do software
projects and manage software projects
and architect them but I also do things
like this where I'm
Consulting in litigation and sometimes
testifying and litigation
uh have you taught any courses
yes I'm an Adjunct professor at Nova
Southeastern University and what classes
do you teach there I teach computer
security and the Unix operating system
environment although since covet I
haven't been doing that and have you
published any scholarly articles
yes I have two published articles one
related to
computer security and another relating
to antitrust enforcement using
technology
and what experience do you have in
statistical or forensic analysis of
social media
a bunch of the Consulting work I've done
involves analyzing data from social
media
um most of them have been
Consulting for litigation some of them
are Consulting for non-litigation
um
yeah
and does that work both in civil and
criminal matters yes and could you
describe the work just a bit more in
terms of what you've performed regarding
statistical or forensic analysis of
social media I can't talk about the
specific cases because I haven't
testified on them and some of them are
awaiting indictment most likely but in
general it's it's really the same sort
of stuff I've been doing here analyzing
data from the social networks
and what social media platforms have you
performed forensic analysis all of the
major ones what are some of what are the
major ones Twitter Instagram Facebook
Reddit
how much of your expert work is for uh
plaintiffs versus work for defendants
well I don't consider myself working for
either plaintiff or or defendant I I
take my role as an independent expert
extremely seriously
um but looking at who whose Council has
hired me over the you know nine or so
years I've been doing this it's almost
exactly equal
and how many times have you been a
Consulting expert
including litigation non-litigation
hundreds how many times have you been
qualified in court arbitration or in
sworn Court testimony to provide expert
testimony eight times
have you ever been disqualified as an
expert by a court no
do you believe that your testimony will
be helpful in assisting the jury
understand the facts of this case I do
you're on Earth this time I tender Mr
Schnell is an expert in the fields of
statistical and forensic analysis of
social media any objection your honor
can we be hurt do you want a boy dear
yes I do okay
thanks
sir my name is Wayne Denison good
afternoon good afternoon uh
you may hear an analysis of certain
tweets and hashtags right right
and you made no effort to connect those
tweets and hashtags to the statements
Spain made by Adam Waldman I'll sustain
the objection the voy deer is just for
his qualifications as an expert
can we be heard Veronica if you want to
come thank you
foreign
as an expert
all right then I'll move him in as an
expert at statistical and forensic
analysis of social media okay
yes sir your question Mr Schnell what
were you asked to do in this in this
matter
so I was asked to do several things I
used the official Twitter apis to bring
in data over certain
several different time spans
initially it was April of 2020 to
January
2021
and analyzed various hashtags and things
like that
and what is significant about April 2020
I understand that April 2020 is related
to
um the alleged defamatory statements by
Mr Walden
and
you what sir you talked about apis what
what is it what does that mean API
stands for application programming
interface that is a service that's
provided by companies like Twitter so
that professionals can write programs to
a query Twitter to ask for various
things in this case I use two of their
apis one of them is called the search
API and that allows you to get Search
terms and it will return all the tweets
containing those Search terms through a
certain date range the other one is
called accounts API and I use that again
through a certain date range to return
any tweet that contained that hashtag
and you just and I should add that it
may not be obvious why you need to do
this but if you just do a search on
Twitter itself it's not going to return
everything it's going to return a subset
of what is out there
um but using these apis which you pay a
lot of money for uh they sort of
guarantee that you'll you'll almost
guarantee that you'll get everything
and you mentioned hashtags I know a lot
of people know what that was our vote
for those who don't what's a hashtag
well hashtags are a function of Twitter
they're really just part of the text of
a tweet
um or or profile and it it's convenient
to put things in hashtags so that when
somebody searches they can search for a
particular hashtag and it'll it'll come
up
and um did you uh choose particular
hashtags to search for I did and how did
you choose which hashtags to use
well initially I was looking at uh
tweets that would be negative towards Ms
heard so um I looked through uh tweets
that were negative towards Ms heard and
I found that uh a super majority of them
were using one of four different
hashtags
and so overall what did your analysis
find regarding negative hashtags about
his herd from April 2020 until the end
of January 2021. well there were over 1
million 243 000 and change
um uses of those hashtags during that
time frame you just mentioned
and did you perform an analysis of the
negative hashtags from April 2020 until
January 2022. yes I did and what was the
result of that there were over another
million so you know
2.38 million I think
and how did you determine that the
tweets were negative about misheard
well you know I hadn't been asked that
until later on in this but I didn't
think that that would be in controversy
I mean some of these hashtags are are
pretty rude and uh it it would really
surprise me that anyone would think that
they wouldn't be negative towards Ms
heard but when um when I was asked about
it later I um actually took a random
sampling and looked at them and and
could not find any that were not
negative towards Ms heard and what was
the random sampling that you used
I did two of them they were a thousand
each and how did you determine which
thousand uh tweets to use and to review
in each search I wrote a program that
truly selected them at random
and in your experience uh is 2000 tweets
a meaningful sample
so I've chosen at random in this in this
universe yes okay in addition to the
four hashtags for miss her did you um
review any other you look at any other
hashtags I did and what hashtags did
what type of hashtags did you look for I
looked at what I found to be six
hashtags that would be negative towards
Mr debt
okay but Michelle could you put up um
the monster to one
which is on the fifth page of Mr of
attachment four of Mr schnells
expert designation
um
Mr Mr Schnell
did you create this chart I did
and what data is this chart based on
this is based on the um the search API
from Twitter and it rolls up the number
of tweets with the various hashtags by
month of each of these two years
took me three years your honor I'd like
to make this a demonstrative Chanel uh
Chanel demonstrative one or do you want
it to be if I could get it one of the
numbers and said it's going to be part
of the record just okay um Can can we
call it Chanel demonstrative one and
then I will give you a number
well the last number I have is 1837 I
don't know
do we know if that's the last um
can we make it can we
how about we make it 1900 that way it's
not how can we just make it 1900 perfect
okay all right 1900 it is any objections
of demonstrative no you're all right
polish that
and is this the is this a chart you made
uh Mr Schnell it is okay and
the at the top here there are hashtags
that are in yellow you see that I do
okay and if we go all the way to the to
the right
um well first let's scroll over to the
left here I apologize you see in 2020
there's the months of June and July
I do okay and what it what are these
columns first tell the jury what they
represent
so each of these is the number of tweets
with the hashtags
um with the corresponding hashtag during
that month okay
and if we look at the first one in
yellow
uh you see that first hashtag the fourth
one over I do
and are there any
what does it show from 2018 Frank to
July of 2020. there weren't there were
none
and then what happens in August of 2020
well there's a remarkable jump from
July to August of 2020 it goes from zero
to thirteen thousand eight hundred
seventy eight and if we scroll to the
right
the last three hashtags uh which are
highlighted are shows the difference
between June and July what what did your
analysis show
well you can see that June is is about
at its steady state
um in July there's also a remarkable
jump
and that's where all three of those
hashtags that's correct okay
and and the hashtags if we if the
hashtags that are in blue are the ones
related to Mr Depp correct correct okay
oh by the way what is your understanding
of when the last alleged defamatory
statement was made by Mr Depp through Mr
Waldman
my understanding is that it was the end
of June about here of 2020 yes
now looking at the hashtags that are
highlighted in blue
for Mr Depp
for the months of November December
November and December of 2018 and
January of 2019. what did your analysis
what is your analysis show
well I see a remarkable jump in November
of 2018.
um and and then it starts to well it
goes way down in December of 19 of 18
and January of 19.
and do you know when Miss heard wrote
the op-ed in this matter my
understanding it was is that it was
December of 2018.
and if we go to
November of 2020 for the hashtags
related to Mr Depp
if you see the difference between
October of 2020 and November of 2020
what do you see there
I also see a large jump from October to
November of 2020. okay and if we look at
the um last hashtag
in blue that says Johnny Depp is a wife
beater
what does that show in term what did
your analysis find in terms of tweets
without those hashtags
it looks to me that also I mean there
are none prior to well a little here and
there there are single digit ones but
prior to November of 2020 there are
basically none and then it jumps up to
over 2000.
and you know what happened in November
of 2020
my understanding is that's when the UK
trial ended
okay we could take this down
and can you put up
um the monster of two
which will make 1901 if it which will
identify as 1901. fine 1901 any
objection
all right 1901 can be published
and Mr Mr Banya um what is what data is
this chart based on
oh I did the same thing Mr Schnell what
that is this chart based on
uh this chart is actually based on the
data we
um just looked at uh but out until
um January of 2022
um and it's it's just another way of
displaying the numbers in graphical
forms so that we can see Peaks and
valleys and what are the what are the
data what are the dotted lines
so if you look at the top you can you
can see
um that the dashed lines are the
negative hashtags towards me as heard
and the solid ones are the negative
hashtags towards Mr Depp
and what do you what is being shown here
what do you in your analysis what is
shown with the uh tweets related to
misheard
um well you can see that there's a huge
uh spike in February of 2020 which I
believe uh Mr Waldman just testified
that that's when he leaked an audio tape
of some kind there's also a notable
remarkable spike in July of 2020 in
November
of 2020 and then in March of 2021
and the spike in February 2020
um
that
that came before the alleged defamatory
statements correct
which one sorry the spike in in yeah
February 2020. that is correct and even
though that Spike came in before the uh
alleged defamatory statements
um
even taking account for that Spike what
time period has more negative tweets
about misheard before or after April
2020.
right so even taking into account this
this really large like in February of
2020 and and you look at from the
beginning of 2018
until the beginning of 2022 there are a
majority of the negative tweets are
between April of 2020 through the
beginning of 2022.
and do you recall
um at your deposition being asked
that it's Spike that a spike in negative
hashtags occurring before April 8th
right before April 8th 2020. objection
hearsay
I would ask about his attorney
good I remember questions regarding
particular dates yes
and what's your understanding as to why
there was
um more uh
negative Tweets in April 6th and April
7th and April 8th 2020.
objection no Foundation
was there more negative Tweets in April
6 on April 6th and April 7th than in
April 8th 2020 as it relates to Missouri
right if you if you look at the day by
day
um
counts which I supplied to Mr Depp and
um you can see that this there's a spike
that begins on April 6th and goes
for a few days so in April 6th is my
understanding before what people are
calling the Atlantic defamatory
statement and did you look at the tweets
for April 6th on April 7th I did and
what did you find I found uh that there
are Wildman statements that are the same
as on the 8th on the 6th and the seventh
um The Daily Mail on the sixth and um
Vanity Fair on the seventh and what term
what terms were being used
um
well hoax is certainly used in in each
of them
I think abuse hoax is used in one of
them I don't have it in front of me but
generally speaking the same in the
seventh I think it's the same exact
terms that are used in the one and the
eighth but the six may be slightly
different but it has the word hoax okay
if we can go to the second page of this
uh the monster rib
what's being shown in the second page of
this demonstrative so this is generally
it's the same data as the first one but
I've removed uh one hashtag the justice
for Johnny Depp hashtag because it kind
of overwhelms all the others because
there are so many of them and by
removing it it sort of rescous the graph
and you can see the others much better
and even though they looked really tiny
in the in the previous page you can see
that they're big numbers you know over a
hundred thousand and stuff so
um this really this shows and if you
look between the two you can see that
the the curves are the same so it shows
like a mathematical correlation between
all the hashtags
so what do you mean by mathematical
correlation well they're correlated you
can see the the numbers go up and down
at the same place so so I'm
understanding the hashtags are
essentially all going up and down at the
same times correct okay
thank you and can we put up a
demonstrative exhibit three
1902 1902. yes thank you
any objection in 1902
no there's a demonstrative yes okay even
publish that
Mr Mr Chanel did you create this chart I
did
and and what what is this chart show
so what I did was I I took the data that
I supplied uh to Mr dapp uh which was
the original data from April of 2020
through January of 2021 and I searched
it uh for certain key terms
um specifically hoax fake and fraud and
that's that's what it's representing the
top part anyway and the top part if you
look at the
for a hoax taken fraud within the and
this is within the negative hashtags or
it's misheard right this is only
searching through the ones that have one
of these four hashtags in them okay and
and if you look at the total oops I'm
putting that in Black let's clear that
oh you saw the line there What's the
total number of um
times it was used in the in the negative
tweets either hoax fake or fraud
81 121. and did you perform any other
searches on the data yes and what what
searches did you perform
so I also looked in that same data
for references to Waldman by itself
or walled and Then followed by anything
followed by mignon or minions minion
depending how you want to pronounce it
sort of a portmanteau of Waldman and
filet mignon I guess or minions
um
and looked for those in in the same data
and in terms of the percentage of the
amount of times Waldman or Wald mignon
was used in the negative hashtags from
April 2020 through is it January 2021
the percent yeah what's the percentage
Yeah so I found over 25 of the negative
hashtag tweets or one out of every four
on average had either uh Waldman or
Waldman Young
and I see Iran searches for hoax fake
fraud rather than
abuse hopes in quotes or sexual violence
hopes and quotes why why didn't you run
those searches objection compound
overall
so I um
so if I put them in quotes like that say
abuse hoax in quotes that would require
that it'd show up in exactly that way
with the same spacing in the same order
so if it said something like there was
abuse and there was a hoax it wouldn't
get caught
um so if I take the quotes out and
search for them separately search for
things separately I'll that'll cover it
and make sure that I catch everything
and
based on your analysis of these searches
within the negative hashtags um what are
the what are the results of these
searches mean
well um obviously I can't read what's in
people's minds but um you know when when
I read the um the disclosure of Mr
Depp's expert Mr Banya he stated that if
these terms uh particular the Waldman
Waldman term
um fiction hearsay
he's an expert
if if these terms had shown up
um a lot of times in the negative
hashtag tweets then that could show that
um they were you know paraphrasing the
impetus of
um why people tweeted these so I sort of
adopted Mr banya's opinion on that and
found this large number so I I agree
with with Mr Depp's expert that this
could show
um a substantial correlation
and to what level of confidence do you
hold the opinions you just provided to
the jury
to a reasonable degree of scientific
certainty uh thank you Mr Schnell I have
no further questions all right
cross-examination
sir this is the first time that you've
testified as an expert
as in the field of statistical and
forensic analysis of social media isn't
it
I've I've consulted on litigation for it
but it never got to testimony that's
correct this is your first testimony
testimony yes and this is and you've
never been involved in a defamation case
before that's correct
and
you're being compensated for your time
here today and the work you did correct
Berkeley research group is being
compensated yes at 600 an hour that's
what they're getting paid right
um and you're aware that Mr Depp is
being sued based on allegedly defamatory
statements
what are the dates of those statements
I um my understanding is it's
um there was
something around April 8th
I believe April 27th and
June 24th somewhere in the end of June
okay
um so
and where do you understand those
statements to have resided
in the public media
in any particular
article or
I didn't consider that all right so
you're not offering an opinion on how
widely the articles that contain those
statements were read that's correct and
you're not offering an opinion
as to how many people actually saw the
language that's been attributed to Mr
Waldman only a minimum number of people
who could have seen it based on the
tweets that referenced them okay
um
and you don't know
even where those references appear in
the articles
I'm not sure what you mean there are
statements by Mr Waldman that appear in
articles do you understand that I do do
you know in what portion of the Articles
the statements appear
I've looked at the Articles and from
that I I've seen where they appear and
that and where in general do they appear
in the middle of the end what's your
sense
that I'm not sure of I mean the ones I
looked at on the sixth and seventh I
think they were
towards the top all right so you
testified that you reviewed a number of
hashtags that you deemed were negative
towards misheard
that's right yes yeah and the four you
picked at least the negative ones
Justice for Johnny Depp
that's from one of them right that's
right
Amber Heard is an abuser
that's one of them that is one of them
we just don't like you Amber
that's one of them that is one of them
and the last one was Amber turd right
that isn't that is another one okay
um and these four hashtags you
identified and searched for
you have no
you don't believe they have any
connection or you testified that you
have no connection to these three
Waldman statements
the hashtags aren't aren't connected to
Waldman right I did an additional
analysis that did show how many of those
had Waldman connected to them and I
found that one out of four of them did
right
but when you were deposed you were asked
whether whether these were related
these particular hashtags were related
to any of the Wellman statements and you
said no at that time I said more than
that I I did I said I I said I didn't
know and then and then I said um I'm
basing my
I'm looking at Mr banya's opinion where
he says they would be if they were in
large number and I'm adopting his
opinion and agreeing with him that they
must be connected
so you're adopting an opinion that
hasn't been rendered in this case yet by
anybody but you well I know that Mr
Banya has testified
okay what I'm saying is I know that Mr
Banya Mr Banner's disclosure says that
he is expected to come to that opinion
all right
today in this courtroom is you correct I
would I wouldn't know I haven't watched
everything I've watched a bit you're
you're adopting your own opinion
um no I'm adopting the opinion that I
read in Mr bad news disclosure and
that's not the
I think I did make reference in my
deposition to uh what Mr Banya said and
and that I agreed with it
all right and you
indicated in deposition you didn't take
into account
statements made in the media
correct made in what I could use you
said you did you did not take into
account in your analysis statements made
in the media media
um yes in the analysis where I gathered
data and decided which data to gather I
did not take into account statements in
the media all right
so you looked at data
you produce charts
you did analysis relating to the data
but you had no reason at the time you
did this to consider any particular
statements isn't that true
that's true I think that's an
appropriate scientific methodology to
not to first get gather as much data as
possible and then drill down on the data
data you collected shows that the four
hashtags you would you identified
were in existence before Mr Waldman made
the first statement
April 2020 right
that's correct right and very small
number what but Justice for Johnny Depp
has been around since 2013 correct
um that sounds correct yeah
Amber Heard is an
isn't it first appeared in 2016. correct
I don't recall actually right
do you recall if there was any portion
of Mr waldman's statement that made any
reference to Amber turd
not that I've seen right
people can form a negative opinion of
anyone without reading anything that's
correct
and you didn't consider whether there
was negative publicity around misheard
other than the Waldman statements
well my what I did was to report on uh
correlation uh with with these hashtags
and certain Search terms in particular I
wasn't trying to read anyone's mind as
to why they use them
you didn't form any opinion that of of
the million tweaks million plus tweets
that you looked at
um we're connected in some way to Mr
waldman's statements
I did eventually yes you didn't you did
you did somebody else's report
relative to testimony that hasn't been
given here I did it before my deposition
you have a demonstrative that uh Council
played for you can we put up a playlist
uh 1901 again
this is yours right correct yeah
um
the biggest spikes
by far the biggest spikes here are
attributable to one hashtag
Justice for Johnny Depp hash attack yeah
and there are spikes that existed uh
considerably in
before
Mr waldman's statement you were asked
about that by Council one of them did
that was the date that Mr Waldman leaked
the audio tape the biggest Spike
was before
the statements right the date he leaked
the audio and then there were many
statements
that um
are there many hashtags
uses of the hashtag that follow
the statements
you'll have to be more specific
well so you looked at a million two of
these hashtags right right
in your chart didn't 980 000 of these
Plus
belong to justice for Johnny Depp
that sounds about right you'd have to
show me but I I'll take your word for
you
but the vast majority of them were
a majority of them were well it was you
already so large that you had you had to
draw another chart
the reason for drawing that other chart
is is because
the numbers were high at particular
points so you wouldn't be able to see
the other hashtags
sure and and all of the other activity
at the bottom you can barely see in
comparison to the hashtag Justice for
Johnny Depp
right as I testified you can barely see
them because of the spikes in the
Justice for Johnny Depp hashtag but the
but when you look at the other chart you
can see that those others are still very
large numbers so
that's correct right right you're you're
not a pining as to why these spikes are
there
I'm only talking about correlation right
Right medical
you know why they did uh a particular
post with a particular hashtag that's
correct all right
uh there's a second Spike that appears
to
be in July of 2020
um
yes the pointer was pointing to a
different one but yes yeah
um
were you aware there was a trial in the
in the UK in 2020 I'm aware end in July
um you're saying it was in July no but
we as of that the time of that Spike
there was ever there was uh publicity
around a track correct
I don't know how much publicity there
was I know the trial was going on then
uh
there are a number of things called out
in your chart
um
relative to particular dates December
17th February 11th February 14th you see
all those I do and
your chart makes absolutely no reference
to and does not identify the dates of
any of the Waldman statements does it
sir
not no it doesn't call those out if
that's what you're asking it calls out a
whole bunch of other dates but nothing
relative to the Waldman statements
correct
all right at some time at some point uh
you ran searches for additional Search
terms uh hoax fraud
I think you said fake
um and then
you don't know why those terms appeared
do you
I'm not sure what you mean by that
question
are you asking me
you could not perform a scientific
analysis of the reason why these those
terms appeared in that in the tweaks you
were looking at right I could only show
mathematical correlation but you could
show a correlation but but you don't
have any idea why they're there I I
can't get into people's heads right
contains one of the term terms does not
mean the Tweet was in some way prompted
by Mr Walton right
well there are a few things I searched
for the ones you just mentioned and then
the the Waldman and Wald mignon
terms so
you know it's not that big a stretch to
say that it's related to Mr Waldman if
it's his name and wild mignon or minion
wait a minute is is it's the new
standard it's not that big a stretch no
I'm trying to speak I'm trying to right
yes all right so you're not suggesting
that you know why Mr waldman's name
appeared in any of these tweets
well if you look at if you look at the
tweets that have wild mignon
you know and I looked at a large sample
of them
um
just a large sample was
2 000 out of a million two no I looked
at more than that of these but
um that's another thing that I wouldn't
expect to be in controversy
um you know when people are saying that
they're part of the wild minions or
things like that
um I would expect everybody to agree
without arguing that it has to do with
Mr Waldman nobody asked whether Mr do
with Mr Waldman I'm wondering
how do you know that it had anything to
do with Mr waldman's statement
but I was under the impression I was
informed that nobody really knew who Mr
Walden was before all of this so I
wouldn't expect it to be anything else I
didn't think it was in controversy
it wasn't in controversy whether
everyone knew who Mr Waldman was was
that your testimony no I'm saying it
wasn't in controversy that
um that if somebody was suddenly talking
about him that it had to do with this
case
but again it's not did it have to do
with this case it's did it have to do
with the allegedly defamatory statements
you have no idea do you sir I can't get
into anyone's mind I can only talk about
the science of it right
um and so you identified all of these
hashtags as
as negative towards misheard
right right
just as for Johnny Depp is not negative
towards misheard is it
no but the tweets that use that hashtag
are
mesh tag itself the
I'm not talking I'm not opining on the
hashtag itself I'm talking about the
tweets that contain that hashtag
but the hashtag itself is not negative
that's not part of my opinion one way or
the other well
do you have an opinion as to whether
Justice for Johnny Depp is a good thing
that's not part of my assignment
okay but you'll agree with me Justice in
general is a good thing big fan of
Justice all right me too
all right redirect
okay yes sir
um you Mr Chanel you reviewed
um not a large sampling of tweets of
justice for Johnny Depp correct I did
and the two and the tweets that had the
hashtag Justice for Johnny Depp
how many of them were negative toward
misheard all of them
and what percentage of the tweets with
negative hashtags between April 2020 and
January 31st 2021 contain the terms
Waldman or Waldman Young
over
25 percent
one out of four and in your analysis how
far in times are the tweets containing
the terms Waldman or Wald mignon go like
how far to to now
beyond the scope across
he was asking about Overworld
um
so I I think I disclosed at my
deposition that I that I looked further
into
um
2022 and um
found that it continued to go on I don't
didn't see any end to it at all
and based on your analysis
again what period of time had more
negative tweets against misheard before
or after April 2020.
clearly
um double as many from
April to 2021 and that's even including
the February 2020 Spike correct that's
right so that's which and that happened
before April obviously so even if you
put that in there it's still a lot more
after April of uh of 2020 and there are
fewer months in that time period I think
there are 20 or 50 15 months in that
time period and
27 months in the first part and based on
your analysis what if any end do you see
to the negative tweets toward Mr
objection no Foundation
based on his analysis up until the time
I'll sustain the objections okay did you
see any based on your analysis did you
at the end of the time of your of your
analysis what was happening with the
negative tweets toward miss her
to continue to go on
Mr Chanel after your cross-examination
have any of your opinions in this matter
changed no they have not thank you
all right so you can have a seat in the
courtroom where you're free to go okay
sir thank you
all right your next Witness
just sift
thank you Ronald we will be calling
Michelle mulrooney by deposition
designation and we start okay
wait
[Music]
all right you just want to spell the
last name for me it's
m-u-l-r-o-o-n-e-y all right
he States your name and address for the
record
ing
he was California 90067.
Mr honey what is your occupation
I'm uh partner at Venable
key and
attraction
could you just please describe a brief
give me a brief description of your
educational background and work history
okay I um attended USC and received my
undergraduate degree in 1982 and then I
again attended USD and received my law
degree in 1985
um
I then worked for gifts and done in
clutcher until 1991.
and then I worked for an entertainment
Law Firm that was originally called Arts
Shoppers when I joined it
then later
morphed into several names
and then in nine in
2011 I joined Venable LLP as a party
thank you what are your areas of
practice and expertise
um I'm in this by the head of those day
planning the West Coast
Estate Planning Group for Venable
and does that estate planning involve
any aspect of marital estate planning
such as things like prenups and
post-naps prenuptials post options yes
we frequently do me nuts cohabitation
and post-up agreements for online
would you please briefly describe what a
prenups tool and a postnetual is
a prenuptial agreement is where spouses
contract on the economics of their
marriage before they are married married
and they discuss things as the nation
they contract the things as the nature
of the property Community separate
Etc and also things like spousal support
and in a post up the clients do that
after they're married
the same they contract on the same
issues
do you regularly represent actors
yes
um I'm asking very narrowly did there
come a time when Amber Heard contacted
you for representation
respecting a prenup for a postnap
agreement at some point I was contacted
about an Amber Heard prenup
I'm going to show you what has been
marked as exhibit number three and it's
an email
from you to a Dana Lowry and you know
him
yes
and could you please tell us who gain
alone is
she's a family law attorney practicing
in Los Angeles
and
this is David Monday February 2 2015.
and says I look forward to working with
you with you please send me this is from
you please send me the bullet points for
the economics of the deal when you are
back in the office tomorrow I will have
Amber's business manager get her
financial information to me ASAP I also
like to exchange two years of tax
returns but not attach them is this your
general practice let me know think who
did Dana Lowry represent
Johnny Depp
I take it Amber in the actual document
is Amber Heard is that correct
yes okay and
you put your fight
just direct your attention to the top of
the email where it says February
if February 2 2015
uh what if anything does this do to
refresh your recollection on when
approximately you uh were contacted
about representing Amber Heard in
connection with the prenup
it makes the approximate date more clear
to me
okay and based on this when
approximately were you contacted to
represent Amber Heard in connection with
the prenup or close enough
the early part of February the late part
of January or the early part of February
2015.
Ms Mahoney I'm going to ask you to take
a look at what has been marked as
specific number four
and it is a uh an email from you
to Denali which is Mr Dempsey's Council
correct
during this time period correct and it's
dated Tuesday February 3. I'm going to
scroll down first so we get the earliest
part of it and the first part of it is
an email from
Dana Lowry
to you dated February 3rd at 10 13 and
says J slash a deal coins do you know
what J slash a means
I'm going to take you first of all to
the bottom part which is the J slack
fill points do you have an understanding
of what J slash a means
I I believe it means Johnny Amber deal
points absent a prenuptial agreement or
a postnuptial agreement
is California what we call a common law
property state
yeah
what is it
so community property statement okay and
what does that mean
generally means that all earnings after
the date of marriage are owned 50 each
party has an undivided 50 interest in
those earnings
yes
what was your understanding of the
purpose of the confidentiality agreement
it's very standard when you're doing a
pre-natural agreement or a presidential
agreement when either party is
disclosing their assets that they ask
for a confidentiality agreement you
respond on February 17th
Dana I have forwarded to Amber she is
filming a movie but hope to connect with
her by the end of the week I will keep
trying to move forward
I'm asking you what you meant by I will
keep trying to move forward
I assume I meant that word trying to get
a postdoctoral agreement signed between
the parties and that's what I was hired
for
show you what has been marked as exhibit
number seven
and I'm going to start again with going
down to show you where the stream is
here
and it says
are we on on February 17
that's the same email we've seen a
couple times now where she she's
attaching the confidentiality agreement
telling you to have a draft post-nap
agreement but she's getting the signed
confidentiality agreement first
and then I'm going to direct your
attention to the very top part
and that is Wednesday February 18th
from you to Dana Lowry that says Amber
is sending the signed confidentiality
agreement to you
to me I assume I will receive all the
underlying financials list of
anticipated
future revenue streams and documentation
pertaining there too
what did you mean by underlying
financials and a list of anticipated
future revenue streams and documentation
pertaining thereto
I mean this is typical for an actor they
have profit participation
back-ends I wanted to have a list of
what his future Revenue would be he
might have had movies booked
um that he would render Services after
marriage I just wanted to see the
problem
what did you mean by back ends
back end is either profit participation
for royalty
um sometimes it's box office bonuses you
just have to look at the underlying
um
agreement on each movie TV show Etc
to
to track what the revenue will be from
each project and why is that relevant
want to know what they're going to make
during the marriage I want to know the
income during the day
and those are all components of what
they make during the marriage correct
text okay thank you
all right and then you said I can't
really comment on the document until I
get this information what document were
you referring to there
at the post-depth agreement that she
would send
how much time expired between when you
were sent the confidentiality agreement
for Amber Heard the sign
and when you indicated back to council
for Mr death that Amber is sending the
signed confidentiality agreement to you
the next day
What affected communication
did you receive from Mr death
in connection with the post-nap
agreement
I received one telephone call
and whom did you receive that telephone
call from Mr death
please describe the telephone call from
Mr Devin
my recollection is that he was very mean
um that he called me names
and that he fired me on behalf of them
when you say that he was very mean what
did you mean
well my only exact recollection is he
called me a [ __ ]
Mr Depp called you a [ __ ] on that
telephone call hearsay lady
and if any observations did you make
during the telephone call from Mr Depp
during which time he called you a [ __ ]
I thought he was under the end why did
you think that
he was slurring his words and his speech
pattern
was similar to my children's speech
pattern when they are when they were in
different things I was such an extremely
rattled by the call when I was on the
phone for a very short time with him
because he was represented by Council
and I was
I didn't want to be rude and hang up but
I told him I had to hang up
like after two or three minutes after I
realized what was happening
it took me very off guard
and
um and I that's all I remember is that
it really Shook Me Up
after that phone call did you perform
any further services from this heard in
connection with the post-nuptial
agreement no
do you recall ever seeing a post-nuptial
draft agreement
now
has either misheard or Mr death
contacted you at any time after
the call with Mr death respecting
pursuing a post-nuptial agreement
no
who if anyone was paying
Legal Services
I don't recall
was it your understanding that Mr death
authority to fire you
yeah
did you tell him that
I don't recall
and isn't it true that he wouldn't have
had the authority to fire you
were paying for your legal services true
what if any Communications did you have
with Dana Lowey
about your conversation with Mr Depp
after the conversation with Mr death
I don't recall specifically
what do you recall generally if anything
I I do recall that I told her that I was
no longer representing out
but I don't know if I got lighting
somehow she knew
but and correct me if I'm wrong but I
believe you testified that Mr Depp did
not have the authority to fire you
correct
correct miss mulrooney when did your
attorney-client relationship with Miss
heard relating to a potential
post-nuptial agreement terminate
shortly after that
when you say shortly after that phone
call
um
can you give us a time frame of how how
long it was after the phone call
within a few days
one he didn't he didn't have the power
to fire you correct
do you have any recollection of ever
receiving
any more Communications from Dana Lowry
furthering the post-nuptial agreement
after Johnny Depp called you and told
you he was firing you on behalf of Amber
from causing names no substantive I
recall that there was no more
substantive conversations
is there any question in your mind that
it was Mr death who called you
no
yes ma'am your next Witness
yes Sharon we'd like to call the Disney
corporate representative
would you please state your name and
your business address for the record
uh Tina Newman Walt Disney Studios
motion picture production live action
500 South Buena Vista Street Burbank
California 91521
and what is your current occupation
I'm a production executive
and what is your job title
that is my title production executive I
work in the live action feature division
for Disney is it your understanding
you're testifying on behalf of Walt
Disney Motion Pictures group
yes
were you involved in the Gathering of
the documents responsive to the
documents of Kenneth Disney
uh yes I did provide some documentation
to Alec and his group from our
production group I'm going to ask you to
take a look
remember it's subpoena Duke has taken
paragraph number two
and it asked for documents relating to
this case in fact and then it also says
specifically the specifically includes
the op-ed by Ms heard and any impact it
may have had on the above and that
includes as it's defined above including
the business relationship of Mr Depp
including considering Mr Depp for any
work with Disney or future Pirates of
the Caribbean will lesser or greater
role a different role or a different
production
do you recall seeing in any of the
documents you reviewed either being has
been involved as a corporate designee or
in preparing as the corporate designee
do you recall seeing an op-ed written by
Ms heard
no
do you recall in your preparation as the
corporate designee of Disney and your
review of the documents that were
produced by Disney any document that
referred in any manner to the op-ed
written by Ms heard
I would say no
remember
any of the documents you reviewed that
were produced by Disney in response to
these subpoena Lucas take them
um the word op-ed in any of those
documents
I don't recall that no did you have any
discussions with anyone at Disney about
any future Pirates of the Caribbean wall
a lesser or greater wall a different
wall or a different production
no
did you have any discussions with anyone
at Disney about the impact of the op-ed
by Ms heard on
the relationship between Disney and Mr
debb including considering Mr Depp for
any work with Disney any future Pirates
of the Caribbean role a lesser or
greater role a different role or a
different production
no
do you
know whether Mr Depp
is being considered for a role in
Pirates six
no
and when you say no I think I have to
probably ask clarification does that
mean you don't know one way or the other
or he is not being considered I don't
know one way or the other
it doesn't oh I'm sorry go ahead I was
just gonna say
that decision doesn't fall within my
job responsibility it's
above my head
it's the best way to say it so what is
the knowledge you have about pirate six
like I said I just know that it's a
project that's possibly in development
at the studio
that's it
do you know whether anyone at Disney has
ever even read the op-ed written by Ms
hurt
you know are you aware of anyone else at
Disney who has knowledge of the topic
areas in the deposition notice the
deposition exhibit number two
that beyond what you know I can't
honestly say I can't speak for someone
else
like I explained earlier
my knowledge and what my job
functionality is at the studio
at plateaus and there are people that I
work under
and those particular persons may or may
not have more knowledge but I can't
speak on behalf of them
are is Disney aware that Mr Depp has
testified under oath that he would not
take other
Pirates of the Caribbean franchise roll
for 300 million dollars and a million
alpacas
now
with Disney
entertain paying Mr death more than 300
million dollars and provide him with
more than a million alpacas
to be able to obtain his
services for any future Pirates to the
Caribbean wall
no
I'm going to show you what has been
marked as deposition exhibit number
52 2
Alan horn who's that
he was our co-chairman
Disney yes
and Alan Bergman who's he saying he's
the other co-chairman of Disney who was
at the time
Sean Bailey you indicated
president it's our president of
production correct
those who
I believe at the time he was the head of
our Marketing Group
Paul Rader
all readers the head of communications
all right and this is from Angela Shaw
and it's dated 5 10
2017. you see that yes and it says
subject HR
Johnny Depp a star in crisis and the
insane story of his missing Millions do
you see that
yes okay do you have any understanding
as to why Angela Shaw was sending this
communication to this group the two
co-chairman the president
vice president in production head of
Communications on this particular day
I don't know what the intent of the
email is but
[Music]
um
obviously we have a relationship as a
company with Johnny so
I assume that's why she may be bringing
it to their attention
and just to
[Music]
Deb if there is Progressive publicity
relating to Johnny Depp whether it be
positive or negative that would be
relevant to those who would it not
yeah I mean I can't say how it's
relevant to Disney but given that Angela
is part of communications
her job to you know keep the studio
abreast I guess of
anything concerning the company so
it's about as far as I can read into it
okay
and and so that that's your
interpretation of why Angela Shaw sent
this to
the boys to keep them apprised of this
particular uh article on Johnny Depp
would you agree
yeah that would be my assumption
just need 114 through 137 uh
and I'm going to ask you if you
recognize this document
uh well it looks like an internal email
it may be it may have been part of the
disclosure documents this one's from
Alan horn
and I think we've identified Alan horn
before well actually it starts with
let's start down here on June 21st 2018.
all right and then it has a reply from
Sean Bailey sad can you see that
yes what was Mr Bailey's position with
Disney on June 21st 2018.
I believe he was the president then okay
he may have been there I don't know
okay
and and then we have an email at the top
it's to Sean Bailey so you see Janelle
Tipton
um and then it has some copies to some
other people from Alan Horne I believe
we said he was one of the co
directors is that correct no chairman oh
chairman okay uh and Alan Bergman
the other co-chairman
uh and do you have any recollection of
ever reading the Rolling Stones article
about Johnny Depp back in this time
frame
I honestly don't remember if I ever read
this document I may have do you have any
understanding of why
this would be sent from Alan horn to
these other individuals on the top again
same as for
same as before just because of the fact
that we have a relationship with Johnny
so
they may have determined it was
important to bring it to their attention
do you recognize this document
uh yes it looks like a email please
describe
uh it's an email uh
well it started from Scott
to myself Scott sellers is in uh post
Finance
and then I reply to Scott so it looks
like uh an email exchange between the
two of us
all right and you said Scott sellers is
in post Finance correct what what is
that
uh he handles all finances once film
goes into post-production On Any Given
picture also reporting for the studio
internal reporting finances
all right and this is July 14 2018 that
he's sending this to you correct
yes do you recall reading the story that
was in the Rolling Stone the trouble
with young death
I mean to be honest I don't really
remember much about the story but
obviously I must have looked at it
and commented
right and it's the exactly in fact you
commented depressing yeah yes
and just to
go back to refreshing the recollection
on the template do you see that it has
importance and received on this you've
sent it back yes Ms Newman I'm going to
ask you to take a look at what has been
marked as w
W Civic number 56.
and it is a document also produced by
Disney and there's debate stamps Disney
167.
through 177.
and I'm gonna ask you to take a look at
the top here this is two Alan Bergman
from and it has thr's today and
entertainment do you understand what
that is
yes
I'm going to ask you to turn down to
169. it says Johnny Depp's legal team
prepares for court hearing about Amber
Heard abuse claims the actors Camp is
previewing the evidence that it will
present in an upcoming court hearing in
the UK this fall tied should
discriminate that defamation lawsuit
against the Sun for an article that
labeled the actor a quote wife beater in
the quote Katie Kelly reports you see
that yes do you have a recollection of
learning about this and reading about
the UK case in this time frame we're
talking uh
October 2018.
I may have seen a headline come across
my desk in the same manner as Alan
received it but that's probably as far
as it went
I'm going to show you what has been
marked as deposition
number 60.
and it's dated November 5 2020 and it
says Disney reportedly straps plans for
depths potc six I'm assuming that's
Pirates of the Caribbean six return
you see that
did you see it
yes I see it
as you sit here today
are you aware
of any
document
in Disney's
emails or in their I.T system or
anywhere
that contains Amber heard's op-ed from
December of 2018.
I mean no not that I'm aware
are you aware of any
maker
within Disney
who has ever said
they are not casting Johnny Depp in
Pirates six or any other role because of
Amber heard's op-ed
no
are you aware of any decision maker
outside of Disney and by this I'm
including producers directors
people of that ill who have ever said
they were not considering Mr death for
pirate six or any other movie because of
Amber heard's op-ed from December 2018.
no
all right
how much times uh we have an 11 minute
one okay that's fine what's your next
witness Ellen Barkin
all right
b-a-r-k-i-n thank you
good morning Miss Barkin good morning I
think the first thing that would be very
short but very simple and clean for the
record is if you could just describe
kind of your career background I know
it's very lengthy but just give it kind
of
brief summary of kind of when you
started working and what you've done
during your career
um I started acting professionally about
26 or seven and I did theater television
movies lots of them
that they did for four years 40 years
um and uh in the course of your career
acting in theater television movies Etc
did you come to meet a person by the
name of Johnny Depp yes can you specify
in time
Miss Barkin when you met him I would say
1990.
and upon or after meeting him did there
come a time when you became friends
yes and can you describe how that
happened
we just developed a friendship over time
that
lasted I guess if we met in the 90s
maybe 10 years or a little less
and
fair to say that Mr duck at the time was
also an actor a professional actor yes
um were you
um did you act in any film stage or TV
Productions with Mr duck yes I was in
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas how often
would you see Mr duck
when I lived in New York usually
whenever I go to La if I were in La I'd
see him
a week maybe more I mean the Friendship
went
up and down living on different coasts
and did their
come a time when your friendship with Mr
Dave that became more than that became
romantic in
it
yes
and at what point in time did your
relationship with Mr adap take in a
romantic turn
after I had moved to Hollywood
and uh he you know switched the buttons
recall what year you moved all
the Hollywood yes
um
1994. when you said switch the buttons
can you tell me what you meant by that
um the Friendship went from a purely
platonic friendship
um to a romantic
um
at that point in 1994 when the
relationship turned romantic uh to
change that to sexual to sexual thank
you
thank you for how long did your
relationship with uh Mr Depp remain
sexual
several months
anywhere between three and five six
and during that period how
again that period when it was sexual see
I'd seen three or four times a week
again I'm not
details but can you tell me like where
you would see him just give me some
sense of that yeah he would come to my
house or I would go to his house and and
both houses in L.A yes about
um 10 to drive apart from each other and
um
at
either when you were at his house
um
well you didn't stay the night or were
you were at his house when you did stay
the night were there other people in the
house who saw you there who were those
people be
um he had an assistant
[Music]
his sister
that's all I can remember now you recall
the name of the assistant
I don't know his name he was referred to
as Pig
he was referred to by whom is Big Johnny
Depp at any point that you were either
initially friends and then sexual with
Mr Tapp uh we do you become aware that
he uh
um drank to excess I was always aware
explain how you were aware of that he
was drunk all of it most a lot of the
time
and that would apply both to when you
were initially friends and then later
when it became sexual yeah
and what was he drunk what what would
you understand what had he drunk to
become drunk it was a Red Wine Drinker
okay in addition to alcohol
um were you aware at that time that Mr
uh Depp
um was taking any prescription
medication no
um same question Mr Barkin for illegal
substances yeah same question and what
illegal substances
listen to Gen X
cocaine
marijuana
hallucinogenics
can you say specifically what those were
I don't really know
he called me and told me he was tripping
um
with respect to any of that
hallucinogenics cocaine or marijuana did
he do any of that in your presence
yes uh more than once all the time
um when you say all the time how many
times
again in the period that you were both
first friends and sexual then sexual
with Mr Duff do you think you saw I
couldn't even tell you I mean I just
know he was always drinking
and
of course smoking a joy but it would be
fair to say more than at least dozens of
times yeah
over the full course oh yeah
now
did you ever
um observe
Ms Barkin uh Mr Depp's Behavior change
when he drank more or
used more drugs I did not so he was kind
of the same all the time okay
was not the same
he was high
did there come a time
Ms Barkin when Mr Depp
um
acted in a way that was
out of control with you yes
Mr Depp threw a wine bottle across the
room the hotel room on one instance in
Las Vegas while we were shooting fear
and loathing
in Las Vegas were you you was something
about to happen the fight was going on
between you and Mr Doug no who was the
fight between them between Johnny Depp
and his friends in the room the
assistant honestly I don't remember and
the bottle that you remember seeing your
today Miss Parking weather the bottle
was full of wine or empty
I don't
uh sitting here today Miss Parking do
you remember uh whether the bottle hit
you no it did not
um did the bottle hit anyone else no it
did not
approximately how far away from you
was Mr death when he threw the bottle
across the room so maybe by by that
break in the table or a little further
down
it was a toss
and
uh
senior day at the bottle had hit you
would it have injured you Miss Parking
was it your understanding back then he
was throwing the bottle at you I don't
know why he threw the bottle
and was it when he threw it was it in
your direction yes
was there other people standing around
you yes so he threw it in your direction
at a group of people yes whose hotel
room was it
his Johnny Depp
he did how did it come about that Mr uh
death broke after your relationship I
went to go home uh there was a big
goodbye crying a lot of jealous and
don't do this don't do that and
I never heard from him again after that
and did uh Mr Depp not wants you to go
back to Los Angeles
there yes he didn't want me to go I was
only supposed to be there for two days I
stayed for longer
and you just referenced uh you just use
the word jealous how did that come up
what does he say that indicated to you
that he was jealous he's just a jealous
man controlling where are you going who
are you going with what did you do last
night I had a scratch on my back once
that got him very very angry because he
insisted it came from me having sex with
a person who wasn't him during the time
that you were in a sexual relationship
uh with Mr dupp
was it common for him to say things to
you about being controlling to use your
words or being jealous of you
yeah very common
and uh when in these instances when Mr
Depp
became jealous or controlling did he
also become angry yeah
and demand it
ladies and gentlemen is going to take
our afternoon recess please do not
discuss the case and do not do any
outside research okay we'll see you back
in 15 minutes
foreign
does that give you time to be ready okay
all right
thank you
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
thank you
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
yes
okay you want to approach
foreign
thank you
all right thank you your next Witness
foreign
blausting
all right
b-l-a-u-s-t-e-i-n thank you sir oh and
I'm
I'm asking questions first I believe I
may be the only one asking questions all
right thank you
provide your full name
uh Alan it's not blasting
you're a doctor correct
correct and you're a psychiatrist
yes how long have you been a
psychiatrist for
uh since
1987.
and you went to medical school
yes what medical school
Northwestern University now Johnny Depp
was a patient of yours correct
correct you understood that
Mr Depp had substance dependence issues
is that correct
yes
yes do you recall what substance issues
what what substances he had Mr deaf had
issues with
uh marijuana
alcohol
[Music]
opiates I believe
did you ever have an understanding that
Mr death had anxiety syndrome
I knew Mr death had anxiety
[Music]
and how did you come to be aware that Mr
death had anxiety
she told me about
do you recall having any conversation
that Mr Depp was bipolar
or some question about uh
bipolar disorder diagnosis but I do not
remember any specifics about the
discussion
do you recall having a conversation with
Mr Depp about a bipolar diagnosis
no
what behaviors did Mr death acknowledge
that should be changed
uh certainly his drug use uh and it's
turning to drugs for
to help relieve a lot of the psychic
pain that he was experiencing in working
with Mr death would you agree that he
had fundamental that Mr Depp had
fundamental issues with anger I I would
say that he expressed having issues with
anger
Mr deaf Express having issues with anger
did Mr Depp Express having issues of
anger towards Amber
he expressed heading
here towards her yes
do you recall what reasons Mr death told
you as to why he was expressing anger
towards Amber
I can't you know
no I'll have to sit in there
in working with Mr Depp was he ever
suspicious of Amber having affairs
I can recall now he expressed uh
feelings of jealousy
that I don't remember was it by the
powers
you recall any more detail about what Mr
Depp was feeling jealousy toward Amber
about
no
been working with Mr Depp um
did you see that he Mr death had any
issues with patients
yes he was impatient
what is your understanding about uh
issues that Mr Depp had with Amber
it was a very chaotic relationship with
uh
a lot of fluctuations ups and downs and
uh
that's a difficulty and emotional
expressions
and um
lots of anger in both places and you
know high intensity affect emotional
expression
a lot of love a lot of uh disappointment
a lot of fears
Dr blasting I'm showing you what's been
marked this lasting exhibit three do you
recognize this document
yes okay what what is it
it's uh my invoice building document
this is from your your files
correct let me keep this document in the
ordinary course of business
correct and this uh billing invoice is
for is for Johnny Depp correct
correct
and so where it says 10 to 14.
um from your from your billing records
would this be the is this your
understanding the first time you you
met with Mr duck
by phone yes
and
in total
if we look at the number of sessions you
either met or spoke to Mr depth that
weren't
uh canceled or he didn't show up
um
my County comes to 19 18 times you met
with Mr desk does that sound about right
it's like 18 times
did you have any concerns about any of
the amounts of
medications that Mr Jeff was taking
uh I had concerns about the Adderall
and I would have expressed to him
and what were the concerns about the
Adderall
uh I
and I don't recall the specific
conversations but I would have been
asking about uh
how he was diagnosed to have
ADHD or under what circumstances they
would pick bad especially if he wasn't
currently working
if you ever talk to Mr death about
um
what he did when when Marilyn Manson
would visit
you know
when you were working with Mr deck
did you have any understanding whether
Mr Depp was still
abusing drugs and alcohol or not
yes
but you do recall that there were times
in your working with Mr Depp where he
had breakthrough uses of
drugs or alcohol
yeah that was relative sobriety was not
complete yes
and that's what you mean by uh
breakthrough usage that it that his
sobriety Mr deaf sobriety was not
complete
uh
relative sobriety again I said
relatively sobriety because he did
continue to use marijuana throughout
almost the pilot throughout the time I
knew him uh what a short time exception
I think
so I called it relative sobriety then
there'd be some breakthrough uses of
other substances
and when you say breakthrough usage
just so everyone understands what do you
mean by that
uh
he is trying to be sober he was working
on sobriety and uh
by break for uses I mean sobriety with
me the abstinence of using the substance
and so the Breakthrough would be on a
particular time he would have used the
substance that he was trying to be sober
up absolutely okay
so in it in addition to marijuana
in the time you saw Mr death from
October of 2014 through January of 2015
there were other times there were times
where Mr death
broke his sobriety with drugs or alcohol
in addition to marijuana correct
I believe so yes
how did you come to that understanding
you would have told me do you know why
um Mr Depp stop seeing you
I know he was preparing to lead to
Australia to go to work and uh
I assumed that was the replacement
but he hasn't returned to you since he
went to Australia and
in 2015. correct
correct and and did anyone inform you as
to why he stopped seeing you
lasting exhibit nine
are notes reflecting your care of Mr
death correct
right
please notice me within every course of
business for
right and you kept these notes in a file
correct
correct
and this is page one of those notes from
October 2nd 2014. correct correct
again there will be plenty of places
where I don't remember I can't read what
they say they are for my current
detention purposes only on these in
these particular notes okay and that's
what makes them process that
in working with Mr debb did he discuss
any
um
abuse he received as a child or an
adolescent
yes
and do you recall any difficulties that
Mr death was talking to you about in his
relationship with
his fiancee
no nothing else
what does it say
such a pain in the ass
you recall why he was saying Amber was a
pain in the ass no
and what what's the next thing say
uh well in boxes about his kid's mom
okay
and uh
again I think I have the word
destructive
what was destructive referring to you
know I don't know no I don't
uh something relationship 14 to 15 years
mother of my kids
uh the by the official officially
um he didn't want to be his dad I think
I'm not
abandoning like his dad and then below
kids it says uh clear better
she needed me to be all this
needed me to be
all this week or
all this work I don't know return to the
next page uh it says page two
got it
and then what's the next client say
is this violence rage that we've had
over a couple years
okay and so what is Mr deck referring to
there
so do you recall that in in working with
Mr Depp that he spoke about
um violence and rage in other
relationships
in addition to his relationship with
Amber
or rage and Chaos I uh
Remember Violence but uh
I do remember region chaos now again in
the context of this is this is by I had
met him at this point
this is open the initial telephone
consultation
so uh to see whether or not
he was going to start therapy with me
but and you're working with Mr Depp was
he talking about rage and Chaos with
relationships in addition to his
relationship with Amber correct yes yes
what what other relationships was he
talking about rage and chaos
again I don't have the specific
recollection but I think it included his
uh
the mother of his children and
um and arguments about uh
Trump that trial of custody child care
or visitation or access to the children
on the left it says uh raise two kids 15
and 12.
and then below that she tried to protect
me
she tried to protect me too
you know what that's referring to
my Association now is his sister but uh
I don't
I don't think that's true I don't have a
specific recollection now
uh
wouldn't take fear
wake up to fight devil
wait uh wait up to the fight devil you
know what that's referring to wait after
fight devil
can you refer to a devil as
some version of uh internal depression
and Chaos that he felt something like an
everyday phenomenon because he was uh
struggling
yeah I think but label that as a devil
so Mr Depp label labeled
um
is
something he that was internal to him as
the devil
as as a representation of something
horrible inside of himself whether I
would
say so the devil was something horrible
inside of himself correct
again I don't think he ever said that so
I'm good to be careful here
um
the devil was the representation of the
battle that he had many days when he
woke up with the depression and then the
anxiety and fears that he had
did Mr Depp ever refer to himself as a
monster
remember the word monster in my office
but I don't know referring to himself or
not maybe that'll be more revealed as we
go forward
now
turning to blasting 12
um with the page four of this exhibit
and there's a three at the top correct
yeah and then to the right it says that
says Amber fiance correct
correct
and then work through anger just below
that
and we're saying work through anger is
that referring to
his anger towards Amber
I think what uh he was saying about this
that part of his goal of therapy was to
work through anger that he and his
fiancee had towards each other
um then going back to the left
uh better with girl about it
self-destructive hard to not put in
front of me
you know what's self-destructive hard
not to put in front of me means it's
referring to
I think a self-destructivist is drug use
that's what I'm referring to at this
time I'm now looking at blastian 13 uh
which has a page four
are you there I guess uh okay and at the
top it says uh Johnny slash Debbie
correct correct all right
um and then the date it says 10 slash
what
I think that's 10-7 and so it says JD 10
21 14 correct correct
uh a lot of things work intense work
fatigue
be in a minute
here I can say with certainty his words
[ __ ] with my girl
and what's that referring to
difficulty was having with Amber
and you recall what he was talking about
what difficulty he was having with Mr
Depp was having with Amber
yeah
the next line looks like it says she
refuses to accept
correct
do you know what amber refuses to accept
what Mr duck was referring to
nope
and to the right it says Amber what
Amber wedding you were were you talking
at this point about potentially Mr Devin
Amber Murray
yes he was talking about that yes okay
um
and then what does it say under she
refuses to accept
uh wedding February
and then what's next
uh not want to go to marriage 51 years
old
did were there any discussions that you
had with Mr Depp um
where he had concerns about the age
difference between him and Amber
uh I don't think so I'm not okay
but what does it say under 51 years old
uh a lot of Life Experiences
uh you're being my mother and psychotic
sister
what did you understand Mr Depp was
referring to or you wrote you're being
my mother and psychotic sister
I think that's something that he said to
he told me he said to her
and Mr Depp said to Amber you're being
my mother and psychotic sister
that's what I would think yes okay
then the next line high tolerance for
marijuana
who has a high tolerance for marijuana
and he did
I turned into the next page
um which is blasting 15 and where I have
a number five on the top there
what is itself something
self-destructed very early
and with Mr duck talking about itself
being self-destructive very early
yes
okay how was he being how is Mr death
describing that he was self-destructive
[Music]
you know I think
I again I don't recall but let's
continue and maybe something's there
so he was trying to he was trying to be
sober from booze and pills correct
correct okay
okay and then it was it you who said a
reward
yeah asking him about where where can he
get rewards elsewhere
where did he get the reward I may have
he asked him where did he get rewards
elsewhere and there he said uh in the
past and the MAA ecstasy cocaine
so so what did you understand where you
wrote mdmaax to see cocaine
it's not quite sure but those are the
things that he had used in the past
now there's always another possibility
that I had asked him specifically about
that but I don't think it's more likely
that uh
that those are things get used in the
past
do you know what pills Mr Depp was
referring to to be sober from
uh I know oxycodone was uh I made the
rest of that time
and it says uh back to the left it says
left off
yeah and that's probably a note to
myself
to try to get back to I thought a reward
Loop mechanism
and it's parallel to a relationship what
kinds of rewards could come back to him
that could be healthy what kinds of
rewards that can come from the
relationship that could be healthy
and then uh talk about uh biology
changes
so I made it to myself there to talk
about how the brain changes in the face
of
uh many of these drugs over time
did you talk with Mr deped all
um that his brain can change as
he continues to take these medications
these drugs
uh
yes I did and then it says 10 27 14.
more on relationship issues
being accused in his word a big manic
grounded by seeing children
son is going to the positive aspects of
the relationship Larson was talking
about his past relationship there
Mr Depp was saying that Amber reminded
him of his
mom and his psychotic sister
that the relationship reminded him of
his relationship with his psychotic
sister and
this mother
and and Mr Depp talked about
that he was being accused of being manic
yes did he say who accused him of being
manic
I assuming from this it was Amber
[Music]
turn to the next page blasting 16.
yeah and this is uh 10 29 14 at the
topic
what does that mean attention
uh normal mood attention decreased
um
attention paying attention
memory uh
uh transitional difficulties
and what do you mean by having
transitional difficulties with this
memory
uh it would have been part of a
[Music]
committee about the status tests that I
would have done in the first session
where he would have trouble
uh
holding on to memory of things from five
minutes ago by asking for to remember
three words he may have had difficulty
he would have had difficulty remembering
those three words five minutes later
after distracting him with other
conversation right and then what does it
say after that
uh THC a marijuana as part of issue
tetrahydrocalabanol
that's what PhD stands for so he he saw
THC as an issue with Mr Depp's memory
and attention is that right
well with the transitional memory at
least yes perhaps the attention
uh MSC mental status examination uh more
present more attention
off on dates uh asked when I would ask
him about uh
what today might be I don't know what
today's date was perhaps that's what
that's referring to so Mr death was off
on on
what date that was
finishing to the next page blasting 17.
uh it says JD at the top and then 11 10
14.
see that
yeah I have that okay
um and Mr Depp came in to see you on all
11 10 14.
correct okay
um and what's the first line say some
clouding probably secondary to THC
but what do you mean by clouding
would have been something in the
confusion or something about his mental
state or less less Sharp
less alert perhaps
with an excellent side it says no
evidence of uh
Mania hypomania
what do you mean by that
I didn't see in his presentation any
evidence of mania or hypomania
okay next line
uh discussion about relationships core
issues of trust
Amber says
context
contact
I don't know okay uh fruitless meaning
with her therapist
did you ever observe Mr Depp with Mania
or hypomania in any of your other
sessions
not that I recall
and
at 14 Mr def came in for another
individual session correct
11 24 14. the first line so 15 minutes
late
15 minutes late clear relationship
stabilizing
looking at jealous parts of him
you remember that looking at jealous
parts of him
uh things that make him jealous or what
his role might be in jealousy
and and what made Mr death jealous
uh well about what was happening there
but with Amber I don't know I can't
recall
you see in my next notice it was a it
was a triggering point and my next note
is triggering point uh early break up a
22.
where an actress cheated with a leading
man so was was Mr debt jealous of Amber
being
with other men I don't remember that
specifically
attorney to blasting 18.
uh which looks like it starts at 12 7
14.
yeah
Mr Duff came in for an individual
session
correct
and then it looks like you have paranoia
in quotes
and what he meant by that the elements
were fear envy and vigilance
so Mr Depp told you something about
paranoia
and his elements of paranoia were fear
envy and vigilance as he told you
then there's what what's the next day 12
18 14.
well let's see
uh 12 18 14 yes
um and Mr duck came in for a session
yes patient working
so Psychotherapy on tone it's just
possible there's a phone session that
that didn't mark as a phone session
uh
big fight with girlfriend yesterday
uh struggling with how to separate
let her tell you her feelings
relationship needs to take care of you
her to go to a safe Zone withdraw
different men's childhood experiences
and then uh it's at 1 6 15 correct
that's correct
um and what are these notes say
patient late 20 minutes
um
positive hypnotherapy section
goals to make a beeline to bed
uh using relationships to take care of
the individuals
uh
let's see not logical approach to
members
work
take care of emotions
sobriety continuing and then blasting 20
.
we move down to the last page
and this is for 1 8 15 just to be clear
1815 correct slate vulnerability women
in studio who admired Amber threat did
that mean what did you understand that
uh that probably related to your prior
question that there was a
woman who admired her that he felt
jealous of
let's see the next thing is
something of vulnerability
instance instances of vulnerability an
internal fear parallel to vulnerability
and childhood
inability free or fight only way
what does that mean three or fight only
way three
or four fight or free enterprise the
only way
and uh my understanding of that is
either the be free of the relationship
or fight for it and positive
um
relatedness with Amber through
Dash vulnerability
it um and and 1 8 15 was the last time
you
um
saw or spoke to Mr death as a patient
correct
uh I believe that's true
did Mr Depp describe to you at all how
his jealousy would present itself
whether it was jealous of a man or a
woman in relation to Amber
instead of making him angry it would
make him feel insecure
your next Witness
you're honor our next Witnesses Eric
George he was the attorney for Amber
relating to the op-ed
will you please
all right
your name for the record sure Eric
George e-r-i-c last name is George
g-e-o-r-g-e
and could you also State your business
address please sure
2121 Avenue of the Stars
Suite 2800 Los Angeles California 90067
and what is the name of the law firm
that you work with
Brown
o w n e
George
Ross
O'Brien antiguay and Ellis
and you are an attorney Mr Jones I am
and I take it from the name of the firm
that you are one of the named partners
but what are your areas of practice
litigation uh largely in the business
and entertainment areas
have you handled defamation
I have
where are you barred in other words
where what states are you a member of
the bar sure in California New York and
Washington DC
and are you also a member or Bard in the
United States Supreme Court I am
can you please tell us where you
attended undergraduate and law school
sure at Georgetown for both undergrad
and Law School
what if any service did you have with
the Council of the United States Senate
Judiciary Committee
sure in
is pausing to get my dates correct here
um and
approximately
March of
from 19
99
I began Services Council to the U.S
Senate Judiciary Committee where I
served through uh mid-2000s
what if any service did you have to the
secretary
of Affairs secretary to the governor
Wilson
sure from
about March 1997 to January of 1999 I
was counseled to then Governor Pete
Wilson and my specific title was Deputy
legal Affairs secretary
just have you been recognized for your
career achievements since you have been
an attorney
uh I'll say immodestly yes on various
ways that
uh lawyers are from time to time and
magazines and Publications and whatnot
and what if any uh
recognition have you received as one of
the top 100 attorneys in California
the legal paper annually puts out a list
of the top hundred attorneys in
California and I've been fortunate to be
selected as one of those for many years
and what if any recognition that you had
as being a super lawyer in California uh
the same answer except that's I believe
it's called Los Angeles lawyer magazine
I could have that wrong but again
annually they put out a list of their
Super Lawyers
all right and are you also a member of
the American College of trial lawyers I
am
once
what is one of the what is the one of
the qualifications for becoming a member
being invited to be a fellow of the
American College of trial lawyers
sure so the college reaches out to
individual lawyers who have
distinguished themselves and generally
occupy the top one percent of law
practice and it's an organization
dedicated to the development of
professionalism within the practice of
life
I'm going to now turn to Amber Heard and
I'm going to ask you Mr Joyce how long
have you known Amber Heard
an amber
gosh it's got to be a good
five years
I'm going to be referring to an op-ed
going to use the term op-ed it's
obviously an opinion editorial that uh
Amber Heard ended up ultimately
publishing with the ACLU and so in the
Washington Post December 18
2018. so as I go through and ask these
questions I'm going to be using just the
term op-ed will you be comfortable with
me using op-ed and understand it to mean
that particular publication on December
18th
sure
so what if any legal representation did
you provide to miss heard relating to
the op-ed
she presented to me
a draft of the op-ed and asked for my
Council in terms of
reviewing it
editing it and finalizing it for
publication
when is the first time Amber Heard
reached out to you in connection with
the op-ed and reviewing the op-ed it was
certainly within the time frame of
December 6 2018
in connection with the op-ed
what if anything was your objective in
representing Amber Heard with respect to
the review and revision of the op-ed
I reviewed it and spent some significant
time on it to make sure that there would
be no meritorious claim that could be
brought against her
in connection with a definition or
related type of tort claim and ideally
with that in mind to minimize the
possibility of whoever being sued in
connection with publishing it so Mr
George I'm going to ask you to take a
look at exhibit number nine yes
are you familiar with this document I am
please describe what it is
uh as its title it's a judgment uh
dissolution of the marriage between
Amber Heard and Mr Depp
were you familiar with this document and
its contents when you represented Amber
Heard relating to the review of the
op-ed yes
and what was your objective in
representing advising Amber Heard on the
op-ed in connection with this stipulated
Judgment of dissolution of America
so my objective was to make sure that
there would be no meritorious claim that
could be brought against Missouri in
connection with the publication of an
op-ed whether that is a tort related to
say definition or something akin to it
but also including any contract based
breach claim uh arising in connection
with the judgment
and what if any
what if any indications did you have
from Amber Heard during that time frame
that Amber did not intend to follow your
advice or did not care if she was in a
compromising position or might be at
legal risk
so let me answer that this way uh
really two points number one
uh there was never anything that she
said to me
to the effect that
she was willing to run some risk of
being sued or that she wouldn't listen
to my counselor or anything of that sort
uh number two that uh she affirmatively
did follow in all instances my counsel
with respect to these particular edits
what if any legal advice provided by you
to Amber Heard respecting The Washington
Post op-ed was disregarded by Amber
Heard none to my knowledge
what if any legal advice provided by you
two
was followed by Amber
[Music]
all of it
what if any legal advice did you provide
to Amber Heard in connection with the
Drafting and publication of the op-ed
that was not made in good faith by you
I I act in good faith throughout and
with the best of my abilities
your next witness yes your honor we have
Jessica kovacevic she's uh Amber's agent
and that's approximately 27 minutes what
is the last day before me that's a tough
one
k-o-v-a-c-e-v-i-c all right thank you
good afternoon Mr bosovic and Miss
kavasovic do you know that you were
um here today
in your personal capacity and also as a
representative of your agency WME
I do Mr kavasovich what do you do for
work
I'm a talent agent
would you please describe in just very
general terms what a talent agent does
generally
generally you procure work
for your clients you
um
make introductions you read their
scripts you negotiate their deals and
heard is one of your clients
did Ms heard have a successful career
at the time you began working with her
yes and over the period that you've
worked
with Miss heard as her agent what have
your job responsibilities entailed
um
like I mentioned before introducing her
to producers and directors writers
Studio Executives for curing work for
her uh
introducing her just introducing her to
people that can employ her and then
negotiating her deals
and then dealing with whatever happens
on
uh while she is working anything that
arises that needs dealing with did you
ever at any point in time see Mr Depp
hit miss her
no
were you working with Miss heard when
she was cast in the original Aquaman
she was cast in I was she was cast in
Justice League first
and then the deal was to be in Justice
League the first Aquaman and the second
Aquaman did you assist Miss heard in
procuring the role of Mira in Aquaman
yes was Aquaman a successful movie
extremely
was Miss heard's performance in the film
well received critically
yes
were there any negative views about Miss
hurt's performance in Aquaman in the
Press you mean or what do you mean
specifically well in the press or
otherwise no there weren't any negative
as her talent agent did you attempt to
renegotiate Miss heard salary for
Aquaman 2.
yes
when did you do that
we did that around this time last year
why did you attempt to renegotiate it at
all
it's standard to renegotiate these types
of deals it's normal practice
um
when a movie I mean when Aquaman came
out it was the most successful movie of
all time ever
um so even more so for that reason but
for any successful franchise movie when
you make um a three or four picture deal
like we did
success
uh it's it's typical to go back and
renegotiate the deal
getting to your point why did you choose
to do it last year at this time
um because that's when her option was
exercised and when you did get around to
trying to negotiate
um
and WME successful in doing that correct
uh when did he call Warner Brothers to
renegotiate the next film
it would have been the end of February
last year
what year was that 2
2th at some point
was there were there press reports that
misheard was getting released from
Aquaman to
there were
uh
online rumors for a while that she was
being replaced
when did you first hear about those
um
first I don't know exactly when but it
was way before before it was it was way
before this it was maybe even a year
before this
six months before maybe
so nobody ever told you that Warner
Brothers
misrepresented the reason that they were
replacing this hurt correct
why no I would they did there come a
time when misheard
was restored to her role in Aquaman too
yes at that time uh what were the terms
of her
restoration to Aquaman too
financial terms yes
uh she was going to be making two
million dollars on the on the second
film was that consistent with the
original contract
yes is this consistent with what uh
Warner Brothers originally
gave as the rationale for not using her
in Aquaman to
the lack of chemistry between her and
Jason yes
yes you and me came to
her troll as Mira and Aquaman too was
diminished in some way
when she was sent the script uh she was
sent the script directly which is the
common practice for these films you're
aware that misheard has a track with
L'Oreal correct
yes were you working with Miss heard
when she signed that contract
yes
what's up
uh I bought is that a fake account
that's created to execute a certain
objective
what um
what is your educational background
since high school
College
or what college did you attend NYU
what year did you graduate
2005. what was your major
Communications
when WME first began working with Ms
Hurd as her talent agent
you said she had had some success how
well known was Miss hurt
um
pretty famous
um she was within the industry
you could call anyone and they knew who
she was
um
so she had a certain level of of
Fame she had starred in
movies and shows already by that point
going back and taking a wider lens you
know over the time that you've the
several years you've worked for with
Miss heard
how would you characterize the Arc of
her career
um I would say she was
a known actress when I started working
with her
um since she was the one that you could
call Executives and producers and people
about everyone you know knew her name
um she hadn't yet like reached
um big star status but she was
definitely
um you know
she could get the lead of
an independent movie she could get the
lead of a TV series
um
when I worked with her we
slowly started to like strategically you
know have her work on some more
prestigious projects and work with you
know uh
better directors
and then when she got Justice League
that was a you know turning point for
her
um
and then Aquaman you know subsequently
um was obviously the best you know the
biggest thing she had ever been a part
of
and it's it's
her career now on the upswing with her
being part of Aquaman 2.
no
tell me what you mean why not
um because typically
um
when you have an actor who is in a movie
as successful as that as Aquaman was
um
their career
um totally changes and they're in a
different Echelon they
you know get
way more offers they're just put in a
different place
um position wise with Studios they're
more bankable so they can
green light projects
um all those kind of things are
consistent with when you're in a
blockbuster of that size and
um with her uh that did not happen
um
you know it happened you know very
significantly for her co-star obviously
he's the lead of the film and he's the
title character but
um even you know even a small percentage
of that did not happen for her
um so
that's
that's my assessment what evidence
sitting here uh today do you have
that this caused her career any harm
um because the I mean evidence in that
in my experience and the experience of
my colleagues in in the experience of
this business
um
you your career takes a turn after
something like that you're she was very
well received in the movie at the time
everyone was very happy with her at the
time there was no issues and then to
have a complete downturn after that and
then have that coincide with constant
tweets and negativity put out about her
um I don't have a physical piece of
paper of evidence but
the only logical conclusion I can draw
can you name a single role she has lost
as a result of
any activity by Adam Waldman or anyone
at his behest
um there was a movie at Amazon that she
had been offered
um with Gael Garcia Bernal I don't know
what the the final um title of it is
called now I can look it up it had a
working title at the time
um that they
um took away from her and
um
you know the lead actor who was a
producer on it very much wanted it to be
her and was very frustrated with the
process and no one
no one can say
um out loud we're taking this away from
her because
you know of this bad press because
it's nothing she did and it's it's all
hearsay and it's all you know whatever
but
there's no other reason
now Mr topic you you've testified a bit
about Adam Walden correct
correct
and can you point us to any career
opportunities that misheard has lost
because of any statements made by Mr
Walden I mean the the Amazon movie for
one is one that I is tangible because
that
is an example of something that she had
before all of it that was then taken
away
um
I know that um a campaign she shot for
Todd's via Katie Slater
um was scrapped and not used
um
[Music]
there was not another specific example
because
like I said to you no one
is going to say to me oh we can't hire
her because of these tweets or whatever
they just don't want to hire someone
that has
bad press around them from
you know these accusations calling no
one wants someone who's being accused of
a liar and making something up and you
know abusing somebody no one wants that
association with their project
and directing your attention 10 pages
into the article there's another quote
from Mr Waldman Mr Waldman
States in this article
quote quite simply this was an ambush a
hoax based they set Mr Depp up by
calling the cops but the first attempt
didn't do the trick
the officers came to the penthouses
thoroughly searched and interviewed and
left after seeing no damage to face or
property so Amber and her friend spilled
a little wine and roughed the place up
got their stories straight under the
direction of a lawyer and publicist and
then placed a second call to 9-1-1 end
quote did I read that correctly
it just shows the top part of that on
this page but the top part was was
correct
was w
me aware of Adam's statement Mr
Wellman's statements in this particular
article yes
now you testified a little bit earlier
about there being tweets from Adam I
assume you were taught you were
referring to Adam Waldman is that
correct
yeah
and
what if any impact did it have on Amber
heard's career and career path to have
Mr Depp's lawyer putting out statements
in the press and in tweets that Amber
Heard was lying making things up
creating a hoax of abuse I think that
his comments spurred on uh it just added
fuel to the fire so there was already so
much media coverage and that's what you
observed
that's what I observed I'm going to take
you to Aquaman and I'll call it Aquaman
one just to make it a little bit easier
to understand what if any performance
issues were raised with Amber Curry any
one uh
that was responsible for the filming of
Aquaman
no performance issues raised whatsoever
and what was your understanding of how
Amber tested with the audiences in
Aquaman
my understanding was that she tested
extremely well
and and this is an Aquaman has reflected
all the markers of a very successful
movie at this point yes you testified
earlier that it's quite typical when you
have a series of three to four films in
a in a franchise or a series to be able
to renegotiate as you go into the
sequels do you recall that testimony
yes okay and why is that
um because you make the initial deals
um
you know uh before the movie has done
you know well
um and then when the movie over performs
like that it's just it's a custom in
light of the success of Aquaman
would you expect that Amber Heard would
be receiving endorsements as of this
time
yes and what is the typical uh what is
the typical process that happens after
someone has starred in a very successful
movie such as Aquaman and Amber with
Mira the endorsement Department would
um a combination of offers and then
um
seeking out offers that are seeking out
opportunities
now given Amber's career trajectory
leading up to it immediately after the
success of Aquaman 1.
did you expect her career to go on an
upward downward trajectory or stay the
same
I expected an upward trajectory and why
is that
because in success of a film like that
it's it's usually always the case
and immediately after this the successes
of Aquaman
decrease or stay the same compared to
the previous five years I would have
expected them to increase and why is
that
because her um
her profile had been raised
internationally she was in a movie that
was successful worldwide and when you
are in a movie
that performs that well worldwide your
bank ability is is stronger you can
finance an independent film more easily
you can green light a film more easily
um you can just do more and for more
money
do you recall what the budget was for
Aquaman
the first one um
I don't know it would have been probably
somewhere between
uh 150 and 200 million
immediately after the success of Aquaman
would you have expected Miss heard to
continue to earn at least the fee she
made on Aquaman on future big budget
Studio firms or less or more you
um
that becomes an actor's quote
um surfy
um and uh yes typically like you will
then earn your not on a tiny independent
film you couldn't make that much money
on that but
another Studio film another film at a
streamer or whatever something like that
you would make that much or potentially
get a raise
other than Aquaman 2 has ever obtained
any rules with a budget the size of
Aquaman's
has she been hired for any films with
budgets over 100 million
no
immediately after the success of Aquaman
would you expect the success of Aquaman
and her starring role in that film to
increase her ability to get more movie
studios to be interested in her decrease
or stay the same
increase
and did it
no
would you expect her uh to get more TV
roles
objection and why
why um because I mentioned earlier in
the conversation
um you know TV and and films are so
Blended now and there's much less of a
delineation between picking projects
between film and TV
and did Amber receive more TV roles as a
result of Aquaman the success of Aquaman
no
immediately after the success of Aquaman
would you have expected Amber to start
more than one project per year less or
the same it depends if it was a big you
know Aquaman takes up six months of the
year
big movies take up longer time Indies
you can do a couple of them a year it
just depends so I wouldn't put a number
on it but definitely
um more than zero
and has Amber started more than one
project for a year since then
no
immediately after the success of Aquaman
did you expect Amber to earn between
five and ten million dollars a year for
the next five years I would have
expected to renegotiate on Aquaman 2
most certainly
um
and
so right there
um that would have been significantly
more and
um she would have
yes I would have expected her to earn
more in a combination of
TV film and more endorsements was it
your understanding that
WME passed on to L'Oreal suggestions to
assist them in being able to block some
of the harassing uh Instagrams they were
getting at that time yes all right let's
bring up 30 again please
now did in fact L'Oreal suspend having
Amber Heard on the international women's
day campaign
yeah what the conditions were for for
the for the renewal
um it was just essentially that they
were renewing her
[Music]
um
uh I it was the same fee
um that was the the bulk of it it wasn't
you know like an a raise
um but they were extending her
and
typically coming out of the success of
Aquaman would you have anticipated that
Amber could have negotiated larger fees
for commercial projects yes we would
okay and why would that be
because her profile had been raised she
was you know
um
she had done something super successful
so in typically that's what you would do
that would just be the standard practice
when did you first learn about the
change.org petition that was
out there to try to get Amber Heard
drops from Aquaman too I don't know when
I first saw it
uh were you aware of it as of May 27
2020
yes you earlier uh talked about bots in
response to why Mr chews
questions what if anything was your
understanding of these Bots at this time
during this time frame my understanding
is just based off my own
um mainly based off my own
research just clicking on the the
accounts myself and then discussing it
amongst the team and what did you learn
when you did that
just as I would go through you know
daily just looking at comments or uh you
know just the negative comments
clicking on them many of them were just
kind of accounts made for
this kind of commentary or just accounts
that just had you know no followers no
no post nothing
um or following just Amber and Johnny
things like that
and I'm sorry and so what did you learn
from clicking on to those that led you
to believe they were Bots they weren't
consistent with uh what I know to be
actual Instagram accounts
when you look to set a career trajectory
for an actor who just broke out in a
major franchise film would you look to
other comparable actors careers to
ascertain what type of acting jobs they
could get I
I mean I've been doing this job for
you know um quite some time so I I don't
necessarily look to
one or the other but in general
when someone is in
you know what was at the time the most
successful film ever released
um the natural progression is
growth and
more films more you know more work more
money all of that stuff and when you say
the most successful film ever you're
referring to Aquaman one correct correct
um are comparable actors salaries used
in your mind to ascertain the asking
price for an actor in a similar film are
comparable actors salaries used in your
mind to ascertain the asking price for
an actor in a similar film yes
would you consider Anna Damas
career to be comparable to ambers and
measuring where Amber would have been
after Aquaman won I'm honored to armas
yes I would say that would be a a
comparable
um
um that would be a good comp
[Music]
okay that's it that's it okay
all right ladies and gentlemen we've
come to the end of our our day and the
end of our week
um so I want to make sure you have a
good three days and come back for our
last week of testimony uh and uh enjoy
your weekend I just want to remind you
again of what we need to remember as we
go through the weekend okay so you're
not to read anything about this case
you're not to watch anything about this
case you're not to listen to anything
about the case this applies to
television newspapers magazines the
internet and in the online sites further
you not to read watch or listen to
anything about this case on any social
media networking site or streaming
service in addition you must not
communicate with anyone about the case
whether in person over the phone by
email text or instant messaging or by
any other electronic or non-electronic
means this includes your fellow jurors
friends family co-workers acquaintances
and strangers I also instruct you that
you cannot do any research or make
inquiries about this case whether online
or by any other means for example you
cannot look information up on the
internet that is related to this case or
related to the persons involved in this
case nor may you consult dictionaries or
other reference materials what you learn
about this case is limited to what you
learn in the four walls of this
courtroom when proceedings are underway
all right so enjoy your weekend we'll
see you early nine o'clock ready to go
Monday morning okay
all right and also uh in this matter is
heard and Mr debt please do not do any
posts on social media over the weekend
and no public statements please all
right
um and we will see you on Monday morning
as for the attorneys 8 A.M tomorrow I
thank you for all of your instructions
objections for one through those now I
appreciate that I am missing some
exhibits from depositions that we need
to get so if you get with Jamie so we
can get those and get them all taken
care of for the week another thing that
I'm doing just to give you information
um
where I'm getting it together to do a
laptop for the jurors for deliberations
the laptop is going to be scrubbed and
it's just going to have the audio and
the video files on them okay so they're
going to get me a mock-up by Tuesday
it's just gonna it's not gonna have any
Wi-Fi or Internet or no password so it's
just going to have that on it so once I
get it
um and I approve it I'm going to have it
both parties take a look at it and make
sure everything is on there that's
supposed to be on there and that's going
to go to the jury when the physical
evidence goes to the jury okay it just
seemed like that was a better way to do
it for the audio and the video files
okay as far as times go I can give you
your updated times of the as of this
minute
um for plaintiff plaintiff has used 42
hours and 45 minutes
defendant has used 53 hours in one
minute
so the time remaining for the plaintiffs
is 18 hours and 30 minutes
and the time for the defendants is 8
hours and 14 minutes okay
so anybody have any other issues before
we're done for tonight
all right we'll see you tomorrow morning
8 A.M yes thank you
foreign
foreign